EVERYONE TO THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
COMMITTEE FELT AND MEETING OF
WEDNESDAY APRIL THE TWENTY
FOURTH.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AT THIS
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH
MEMBERS TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
BUT WE WILL ASK ALL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO PLEASE JOIN US
AND IN THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
WE WILL BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE
I HAVE A COUPLE OF ITEMS I WANT
TO JUST MENTION UP AT THE FRONT
OF THIS COMMITTEE HEARING -- IT
FILE ITEM TWELVE AB SEVEN ZERO
FIVE HAS BEEN PULLED AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
THAT IS -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC
STONE'S BILL AND THEN LET ME
MENTION THE BILLS THAT ARE ON
CONSENT.
AB ONE FORTY THREE QUIRK SILVA.
AB ONE NINETY FIVE PATTERSON AB
THREE FORTY NINE CHOI AB EIGHT
THIRTY ONE GRAYSON AB NINE FIFTY
SEVEN WHICH IS THE OMNIBUS BILL
FOR THIS COMMITTEE AND AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY FIVE KALRA --
AND THAT WOULD BE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WITH SUPPORT FROM BOTH
SIDES.
SO WITH THAT -- WHY DON'T WE
START TO SEE MS CRISTINA GARCIA
IS HERE THAT'S?
FILE ITEM. THIRTEEN OF SIX FILE
ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY ONE MS GARCIA WALK AT
CHAIR MEMBERS ON A START BY
TAKING THE CHEN THE COMMITTEE--
FOR THEIR WORK AND THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT THAT I WILL BE TAKING
AN JUDICIARY HERE BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT -- AS PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
ONE WOULD REQUIRE A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO CONSIDER AND ITS
HOUSING ELEMENT.
ANY POTENTIAL AN ACTUAL
GOVERNMENT CONSTRAINTS UPON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING FOR
PROTECT THE CLASSES THE PEOPLE
INCLUDED IN THE INTEREST OF ALL
RIGHT.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS OF LOCAL
LAND USE POLICIES ON THE FRONT
AND AND AND ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
AB FIFTY SIXTY ONE IS AN EFFORT
TO MAKE SURE THAT CITIES AND
COUNTIES CONSIDER THE IMPACT OF
THEIR DECISIONS UPON COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
ME ASK IF YOU HAVE SUPPORTERS
WERE HERE.
THEY ARE TIED UP IN THE SENATE.
ARE YOU SUPPORTING.
OUR GREAT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF MY NAME
IS LIKE A VERSION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN WERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER THE
MARGINALIZED ECONOMICALLY
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
IN OF PLANNING THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS.
IT.
DOESN'T MATTER NOT LIKE HAS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS SORRY WERE
WEREN'T ABLE TO GET A LETTER IN
TIME TO BE REFLECTED IN THE NOT
IN THE ANALYSIS BACK.
HERE ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIANS PART.
ADAM RIGHT WHEN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
LIKE WAYS WE CAN GET A LETTER IN
BUT WE ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THAT -- CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
CESSATION IN SUPPORT.
LET ME ASK IF THERE IS
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEE NOW LET'S BRING BACK FOR
CONVERSATION COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT I JUST WANT TO SAY TO
THE AUTHOR APPRECIATE OU TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS THIS -- WAS A
DIFFERENT CREATIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THE HOUSING CRISIS
AND CERTAINLY ONE I'D PROBABLY
SAY -- BROUGHT SOME DIFFERENT TO
NEW IDEAS TO HOW WE MOVE THIS
FORWARD -- I CERTAINLY.
WE HAD SOME.
SOME QUESTIONS AND I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY SOME SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT HOW WE THINK ABOUT THIS
BUT I THINK YOU HAVE BROUGHT UP
A VERY INTERESTING APPROACH THAT
THIS.
LEGISLATURE OUGHT TO CONSIDER
AND AND SO WITH THAT WITH THE
MEMBERS THAT YOU HAVE TAKEN THE
REQUIRED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DO
AN ANALYSIS.
AND HOUSING ELEMENT A LOT OF ANY
CONSTRAINTS TO PROVIDE HOUSING
TO PROTECT THE CLASSES I THINK
IT IS APPROPRIATE -- THAT THIS
COMMITTEE MOVES IT FORWARD FOR
FURTHER DELIBERATIONS SO WITH
THAT I DO PLAN TO SUPPORT IT.
I THANK YOUAND AGAIN JUST
THINKING TEARS STAFF -- FOR ALL
THE HARD WORK GREAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE WE HAVE
QUORUM WE HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL --
CALL FOR ABOUT.
NOW WE NEED MEMBERS.
WE'LL TAKE A BREAK UNTIL WE HEAR
FROM.
ALL RIGHT LET'S SAY A WHICHEVER
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST.
OKAY.
MR GLORIA HAS FALLEN IN NINETEEN
A. B..
TWELVE NINETY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'M DELIGHTED TO SEE
YOU.
TODAY.
UNTIL I TO SEE YOU.
TOO JUST TODAY THOUGH.
I'M DELIGHTED CO EVERYDAY.
BUT I WON'T BE OFFENDED BY WHAT
YOU JUST SAID.
WE'LL GO IT -- MERRICK ORDER IF
THAT'S OKAY -- A. B..
TWELVE NINETY OR WOULD YOU LIKE
FORTY THAT IS PERFECT OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
LOBBY PRESENT THIS BILL THIS
MORNING.
BUT AFTER THAT I WANT TO SAY I'M-ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS TO LIMIT THE SCOPE OF
THIS BILL -- CURRENTLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
DEVOTED SIGNIFICAN AMOUNT OF
TIME TRYING TO SECURE DIFFERENT
LAYERS OF FINANCING AS YOU WILL
NOTICE CHAIR.
NATURALLY THIS FURTHER DRIVES UP
THE COST OF PRODUCTION AT A TIME
WHEN WE NEED TO BE DRIVING IT
DOWN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAILIES BILL
WHICH THIS COMMITTEE WILL HEAR
LATER THIS MORNING I WILL FOCUS
ON DEVELOPING A UNIVERSAL
APPLICATION PROCESS FOR VOTER
APPROVED BOND FUND PROGRAMS
UNDER EIGHT CITIES REGULATORY
AUTHORITY.
THIS BILL WILL ACQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY TO CONVENE A WORKING
GROUP IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE.
AND NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS TO
IDENTIFY ACTIONS THAT CAN BE
TAKEN TO STREAMLINED APPLICATION
PROCESS FOR TAX EXEMPT BOND
ISSUANCES FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEBT LIMIT ALLOCATION COMMITTEE.
STATE OR FEDERAL LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDITS ISSUED BY
THE CALIFORNIA TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE AND MIXED
INCOME HOUSING PROGRAM AND OTHER
PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED BY CAL HFA --
THAT'S THE BILL IN A HAPPY RIVER
OF SOVIET SPHERE I'VE A RATE --
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE OTHER
SUPPORT IS THE BILL.
IS THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
QUESTIONS MISS QUIRK SILVA.
JUST A COMMENT I EIGHT SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THIS STREAMLINING
APPROACH AS SOME OF US.
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING THAT --
THERE'S NOW RESOURCES THAT HAVE
NOT ALWAYS BEEN AVAILABLE AND
FOR A SMALL CITIES OR EVEN
LARGER CITIES TO NAVIGATE THAT
WITH MULTIPLE -- SOMETIMES
EFFORTS TO TO GET THOSE
RESOURCES THIS I THINK WOULD
HAVE A HUGE IMPACT SO I WELL IT
LOOKS LIKE THERE'S NOBODY ELSE
HERE SO.
I WAS GONNA SAY I MOVE THE BILL
BUT WELL WAIT UNTIL WE HAVE
QUORUM BUT SHE HAD A DISASTER
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS WITH A
LOT OF HOMELESSNESS FUNDING IN
BEING ABLE TO IT AGAIN
STREAMLINED FOCUS DRIVE DOWN
COSTS PUT MONEY MORE MONEY ON
THE STREET.
SO IT'S ONE THING TO HAVE THE
FUNDS THE NEXT STEP IS TO
ACTUALLY GET THE FUNDS.
GREAT I JUST WANT TO SAY.
KUDOS TO YOUR EFFORTS TO
STREAMLINE THE APPLICATION
PROCESS FOR ALL OF THE VARIOUS
POTENTIAL FUNDING SOURCES FOR
FOR FOR HOUSING I THINK I DON'T
THINK ANYONE WOULD DISAGREE THE
GALL AND APPRECIATE THE MOMENTS
YOU'VE TAKEN TO WHAT.
MAKE THIS BILL BETTER AND
CERTAINLY PLAN TO SUPPORT IT --
WHEN WE HAVE COR?
SO MR ANYTHING ANYTHING FUNNY
LIKE TO SAY SIR ALL RIGHT LET US
GO TO YOUR NEXT ITEM TACTIC --
THIS IS AB FOURTEEN OH FIVE
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'LL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT TO
REMOVE THE FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATION FROM THIS BILL --
INDIVIDUALS RELEASED FROM PRISON
FACE SIGNIFICANT OBSTACLES IN
OBTAINING HOUSING STABILITY
WHILE PERIOD PEOPLE EXPECTED
HOMELESSNESS SUFFER HIGHER RATES
OF CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS.
RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES A STRONG
LINK BETWEEN OUR CONSERVATION
AND HOMELESSNESS PEOPLE ON
PAROLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE SEVEN TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO BE SET A DATE --
THAN PAROLEES WHO ARE HOUSED
TRAGICALLY PAROLEES EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS TEND TO CYCLE
BETWEEN HOMELESSNESS SHELTERS
HOSPITALS IN JAIL.
IN FACT THE LA OWES OFFICE
ESTIMATES INCARCERATED PRISONER
COST CALIFORNIA ABOUT EIGHTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR WHILE
THE RATE OF RECIDIVISM IN
CALIFORNIA HAS REMAINED ABOUT
FIFTY DOLLARS 50%.
IN THE PAST DECADE.
UNDOUBTEDLY STABLE HOUSING IS
THE FOUNDATION FOR SUCCESSFUL RE
ENTRY FROM PRISON.
THIS BILL CONFORMS EXISTING LAW
WITH EVIDENCE BASED HOUSING
FIRST PRACTICES FOR DECREASING
HOMELESSNESS AND RECIDIVISM BY
REQUIRING CDC ARE TO PRIORITIZE
PROVIDING PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING FOR INDIVIDUALS EXITING
PRISON WHO ARE AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS.
AND PAROLEES EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WITH ME THIS
MORNING ARE SHARED MEDICAL
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING AND CHRISTOPHER FROM
HOUSING CALIFORNIA.
GUYS WELCOME THIS REPORT.
THANKS VERY MUCH AND SHARON
REPORT WITH THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORT OF HOUSING -- AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF GLORIA SAID
AND HOMELESSNESS AND
INCARCERATION ARE AND ARE LINKED.
AND AS YOU KNOW THE PEOPLE I'M
FOOL WHO ARE HOMELESS OR SEVEN
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE SET OF A
CDC ARE CURRENTLY FUNDS SEVERAL
PROGRAMS TO HOUSE PEOPLE COMING
OUT OF PRISON WHO ARE AT RISK OF
RECENT OF AIDING.
HOWEVER UNDER THESE PROGRAM
RULES CONTRACTORS CANNOT USE
THESE FUNDS TO PROVIDE PERMANENT
HOUSING -- WHICH IS HOUSING THAT
DOESN'T LIMIT LENGTH OF STAY AND
ALLOWS PEOPLE TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY WITH THE LEASE.
PEOPLE OF EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS OFTENRETURN TO
HOMELESSNESS ONE SHORT TERM
HOUSING ENDS.
UNLESS THEY'RE CONNECTED TO
PERMANENT HOUSING WHEN THEY EXIT
THAT SHORT TERM HOUSING.
DATA INDICATE OVER 40% OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE EXITING SHORT TERM
HOUSING END UP BECOMING HOMELESS
WITHIN SIX MONTHS AND THEN IN
EVEN GREATER PERCENTAGE RETURN
TO HOMELESSNESS WITHIN A YEAR.
FOR PEOPLE -- PROLE PRETTY
TURNED HOMELESSNESS INCREASES
RISK OF THIS SORT OF ISM AS
MENTIONED AND HIGH COST REPUBLIC
SYSTEMS.
BOTH PERMANENT HOUSING AND
HOUSING NAVIGATION SERVICES ARE
EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING RECIDIVISM.
HOUSING NAVIGATION ENGAGES
LANDLORDS IN NONPROFIT HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE PRIVATE
MARKET THE HOUSE PEOPLE I'M.
CONNECTS PEOPLE THE BENEFITS AND
HOUSING RESOURCES TO WHICH
THEY'RE ENTITLED AND HELPS
PEOPLE COMPLETE APPLICATIONS IN
ACCESS DOCUMENTATION THEY NEED
TO GET HOUSE.
THESE SERVICES CAN BEGIN THE
WORK OF HELPING PEOPLE FIND A
PLACE TO LIVE EARLY ON SO THAT
THEY CAN ACCEPT A HOUSING RATHER
THAN HOMELESSNESS -- THIS BILL
WILL PREVENT PEOPLE IMPROVE FROM
BECOMING HOMELESSNESS -- FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS AND IT'S A
SIMPLE COST EFFECTIVE SOLUTION --
CURBING THAT PRISON TO STREETS
CRISIS.
I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THE MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CHRIS MARTIN WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA -- BUT JUST WANTED.
TO REITERATE THAT ON THIS
PROGRAM THESE MINOR CHANGES OF
THIS PROGRAM WILL ALLOW --
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS TO EXIT PRISON -- AN
EXIT HOMELESSNESS INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING -- WE KNOW THAT FORMALLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS ARE TEN
TIMES MORE LIKELY THAN THE
GENERAL PUBLIC TO EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS -- AND SO THESE
MINOR REVISIONS TO THIS PROGRAM
CAN REALLY HAVE A LASTING EFFECT --
AND DRIVER.
ME ASK IF THERE ARE OTHER
SUPPORTERS THE BILL.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL [inaudible]
SEEN.
MISS WORKS OF ART.
SORRY I WANT TO BE THE THE OVER
TALKING ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT I DO
HAVE TO COMMENT ON THIS ON THIS
IS BEEN AN INCREDIBLY EMOTIONAL
WEEK AS SOME OF THE BILLS MOVING
FORWARD IN VARIOUS -- COMMITTEES --
I HAVE MANY THINGS TO DO WITH
EACH OTHER SO FOR EXAMPLE I
PRESENTED TO A BILL YESTERDAY
AND HUMAN SERVICES RELATED TO
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL AND
HOUSING -- BUT MANY TIMES WE
KNOW THAT PEOPLE WHO SUFFER WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS ALSO HAVE
ADDICTIONS AND MANY TIMES I'VE
BEEN IN AND OUT OF THE SYSTEM
WHETHER IT BE A COUNTY JAIL
PRISONER SO FORTH.
AND AS I MENTIONED IN THE
COMMITTEE YESTERDAY -- I TO HAVE
A HAD A BROTHER WHO HAS SUFFERED
FROM -- ALL OF THOSE THINGS AND
AS HE WAS DIED THIS YEAR IN THE
FALL. ONE OF THE BILLS THAT.
WOULD HAVE I THINK MADE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE WOULD BE A BILL LIKE
THIS FOR HIM BECAUSE HAD HE BEEN
ABLE TO EXIT -- WHETHER BE.
A COUNTY JAIL.
AND HAD A SITUATION WHERE
HOUSING WAS THERE I THINK THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOVER -- WOULD
HAVE BEEN VERY POSSIBLE IN YET
BECAUSE THOSE WERE NOT THE
SITUATIONS MANY TIMES -- FOR
THOSE THAT ARE RELEASED THEY A
PROBATION THEY HAVE.
PSYCHIATRIC APPOINTMENTS AND FOR
THEM TO NAVIGATE ALL OF THIS --
WITH VERY LITTLE OPPORTUNITY
WHETHER EVEN BE TO DRIVE.
FOR RESOURCES IT PUTS THEM BACK
IN THE SAME SCENARIOS THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN OFTEN TIMES -- TRYING
TO DO THEIR BEST INITIALLY BUT
THEN FALLING BACK SO I
APPRECIATE THIS AND AND I KNOW
THERE'RE WHEN PEOPLE HEAR ABOUT
HOUSING AND PAROLEES.
BRINGS UP THEIR THEY'RE KIND OF
DANGER A MOTIONS AND YET.
WHEN WE KNOW PRISONERS ARE
RELEASED?
WE WANT TO DO THE BEST THAT WE
CAN TO GET THEM FUNCTIONING
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO BE --
LIVING SOMEWHERE.
AND SO I APPRECIATE THIS THANK
YOU AND I SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO JUST ADD --
WE ON HOW BORED SUPPORT OF
HOUSING IS BUT CERTAINLY -- FOR
THE COMMUNITY OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE WE
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY STABILIZE OR
SITUATIONS AND REALLY APPRECIATE.
THE AUTHORS LEADERSHIP AND THE
SPONSORS LEADERSHIPS AS WELL SO
LET ME ASK IF YOU HAVE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS SEC FASTER I BUT WE
HAVE A QUORUM GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR PRESENTATION THANK
YOU SIR.
I'M GOING TO ASK MISS PARKS OF I
KNOW SHE HAS A COUPLE OF ITEMS
BUT ALSO A NUMBER OF COMMITTEE
SHE'S RUNNING TO IF SHE COULD
PRESENT HER ITEMS.
AND YOU HAVE A FILE AND THREE AT
AB ONE THIRTY NINE AS WELL AS
I'D FALLEN FOURTEEN AB EIGHT
SIXTEEN I'D SUGGEST IF YOU COULD
TAKE FOLLOWING THREE FIRST.
YES.
AND THAT'S ONE THIRTY NINE
CORRECT YES HI.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- I WANT TO THE FIRST
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH ARE STILL FUN THIS BILL I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB ONE THIRTY
NINE THE EMERGENCY AND
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING ACT.
AS THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES WE NEED
EVERY COMMUNITY TO ASSESS THE
NEED FOR EMERGENCY AND
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING.
THIS BILL UPDATES CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW TO REFLECT
THE STATE'S HOMELESS CRISIS AND
THE NEED FOR EVERY COMMUNITY. TO
BETTER ASSESS THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES FACING
HOMELESSNESS AND IMPLEMENT MORE
TARGETED TRANSITION STRATEGIES
TO LONG TERM PERMANENT HOUSING
FOR THESE CALIFORNIANS.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO IDENTIFY IN ZONE
AND NOW SITES TO ACCOMMODATE
IT'S EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS AND THE
MOST RECENT HOME.
AND THE MOST RECENT HOMELESS
POINT IN TIME COUNT WITH ME
TODAY WE OF NICOLE WAR WAR ON
MON ON HAD BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
RON KINGSTON ON BEHALF OF THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OF ORANGE
COUNTY.
ON AND WILL GO AHEAD AND START
WITH NICOLE.
HERE.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF AB --
ONE THIRTY NINE THIS MEASURE
PRIORITIZES LOCAL ASSESSMENT AND
STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS IN A TIMELY MANNER.
HOMELESSNESS IS ONE OF THE MOST
URGENT ISSUES FACING ORANGE
COUNTY.
IN JANUARY TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
THE COUNTY UTILIZED NEW
TECHNOLOGY.
USING CELLPHONES IN DUTCH IT'S
HOMELESS POINT IN TIME COUNT
TOGETHER THE MOST ACCURATE DATA
ON THE SCOPE OF HOMELESSNESS IN
THE COUNTY.
THIS INFORMATION WILL BE
RELEASED ACTUALLY TODAY SHOWING
THAT THE POINT IN TIME COUNT HAS
INCREASED SUBSTANTIALLY.
THE INFORMATION OBTAINED
CONFIRMS THE IMPORTANCE OF
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT.
IN PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
WHICH HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
ENDING HOMELESSNESS FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
AB ONE THIRTY NINE KEEP UPDATED
DATA AND LOCAL NEEDS ON THE
FOREFRONT OF DISCUSSIONS OF
HOMELESSNESS.
THEREFORE THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS -- JUST AN
AYE VOTE ON THE MEASURE
[inaudible]
THE SECOND [inaudible]
MR.
TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I TO
SEE IF THERE WERE SOME FOR MORE
THAN ONE HERE.
I'M RUN KINGSTON IREPRESENT THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION ORANGE
COUNTY POLICE TO SUPPORT.
MISS QUIRK SILVA IS BUILD.
HOMELESSNESS IS A MATTER THAT
NEEDS TO BE CONTINUALLY UPDATED
THIS IS NOT MY COULD.
ALL THE OF VALUATION THAT IT
GOES INTO THE HOUSING ELEMENT.
THIS CHANGES SO FAST SO QUICKLY
THAT THIS BILL ADDRESSES THAT
VERY VERY ISSUE -- AND BY BY
DOING THIS THE HOUSING ELEMENT
HAS TO BE REVISED CONTINUALLY AS
OPPOSED TO ONCE EVERY EIGHT
YEARS THAT'S WAY TOO LONG.
MR CHOOSE DISTRICT -- THERE IS A
SHELTER THAT WAS SAID.
DISCUSSED AND DECIDED ON JUST
YESTERDAY HIGHLY CONTROVERSIAL.
BUT NONE THE LESS IT HAD TO BE
DONE.
YOU HAVE TO DO IT IN WE SEE THAT
THE TRANSITIONAL PART OF
HOMELESSNESS -- NEEDS TO BE
CONTINUALLY UPDATED THIS BILL
CANCERS AND SPEAKS TO THAT AND
WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THE MASK OF THEIR OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT.
ACCORDING TO RURAL CALIFORNIA
PURPOSES USUALLY.
ARE THERE OTHERS.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
THE SPRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
I THANK THE AUTHOR OF FOR YOUR
DEEP COMMITMENT A FOCUS ON HOW
WE ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS
PERFECTLY AND IN IN YOUR PART OF
THE STATE'S I KNOW WE ALL KNOW
THAT PERMANENT HOUSING SOLUTIONS
ARE THE REAL SOLUTIONS TO
HOMELESSNESS LONG TERM BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT WE NEED.
EMERGENCY SHELTERS TO HELP OUR
RESIDENTS BE SAFE WHILE WE'RE
WORKING TOWARD BUILDING MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I KNOW YOU
THAT'S WHY YOU'RE DOING THIS AND
VERY MUCH LOOK FOR TO SUPPORT IT.
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO CLOSE
THAT AS WAS NOTED THAT THE POINT
IN TYING COUNT FORMS CHEN COUNTY
CAME OUT TODAY OR WAS RELEASED
TODAY.
AND FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHERE
THERE WAS A CLOSE TO FOUR
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED THAT IS NOW
INCREASED IN ORANGE COUNTY TO
ALMOST SEVEN THOUSAND SO THIS IS
A SYDNEY A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE.
AS WE KNOW.
EVERY COUNTY IS GRAPPLING AND
DEALING WITH -- HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO ADDRESS THIS AND AS
NOTED BY THE CHAIR EMERGENCY
SHELTERS AREA STEP IN THE
PROCESS BUT WE CERTAINLY NEED TO
GET TO PERMANENT HOUSING AND
THIS EFFORT WILL?
ALLOW US.
TO PART OF THE SOLUTION BUT ALSO
COMPLETE THE PUZZLE WE HAVE TO
HAVE CITIES ON BOARD WITH
PLANNING SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO NOTE
THAT YOU'RE COUNTY MY COUNTY NOW
SUFFER THE TERRIBLE COINCIDENCE
OF HAVING THE SAME RECORD LEVELS
OF HOMELESSNESS SO.
THE COURT OUR WORK TOGETHER.
WHEN WE GO TO YOUR THIRD AND
FINAL BILL FOR TODAY -- AND THAT
IS.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB
[inaudible]
EIGHT SIXTEEN OKAY.
SEC.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF ON THE
SAME TOPIC IN A SINGLE ALMOST AS
A BROKEN RECORD THIS YEAR YEAR
FOR ME.
NOT ONLY RELATED TO PERSONAL
ISSUES BUT ALSO PUBLIC.
WE HAVE LEARNED THROUGH THE
STATE THAT -- WHETHER IT'S ONE
CITY ONE COUNTY. ONE AREA FROM
NORTH TO SOUTH.
RELATED FROM THE STATE WE ALL
ARE LOOKING TO SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS NOW MORE THAN EVER
WE SEE THE URGENCY WITH MANY
MANY PEOPLE DYING ON THE STREETS.
IN OUR COUNTIES AND CITIES AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB. EIGHT SIXTEEN THE
FLEXIBLE HOUSING SUBSIDY PULL
PROGRAM.
THIS IS A HUGE UMBRELLA TO SAY.
AS FAR AS FUNDING HOUSING ACROSS
THE STATE HOW ARE WE GOING TO DO
THIS WE KNOW THERE'S A SHORTAGE
WE KNOW THAT THERE IS AN ARRAY
OF NOT ONLY LEGISLATION.
PROPOSALS BILLS AND ALSO
RESOURCES BUT HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE.
THAT THIS GETS TO WHERE IT NEEDS
THE FUNDS GET TO WHERE THEY NEED
TO BE AND THAT WE HAVE
COLLABORATION -- THIS BILL WILL
CREATE A HOLISTIC APPROACH TO
GET PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS
QUICKLY WITH RENTAL ASSISTANCE
AND WHEN I NOTE THAT SOME SOME
HAVE SAID TO ME ABOUT WHAT WHY
WOULD YOU WANT TO PAY FOR
SOMEBODY'S OF RENT THAT'S A
TEMPORARY FIX.
WHAT WE KNOW FOR SURE IS WHEN WE
CAN KEEP PEOPLE IN THERE?
THEIR HOMES THAT BEING RENTED
THAT WE SOLVE AN ISSUE BECAUSE
ONCE SOMEBODY'S EVICTED IT BUT
IT COULD COST UP TO TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO PUT THEM BACK INTO A
ROOM AND OTHER RENTAL AND MANY
TIMES IT'S NOT AN EASY PROCESS.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE AN INFECTION
ON THE RECORD -- IT WOULD
PROVIDE FOR RENTAL ASSISTANCE
FOR APARTMENTS IN THE PRIVATE
MARKET AS WELL AS OPERATING
SUBSIDIES FOR AFFORDABLE
PROJECTS LEASING UP OR EXISTING
PROJECTS WITH AVAILABLE PARTNER.
APARTMENTS.
AB EIGHT SIXTEEN REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO
CONSOLIDATE EXISTING PROGRAMS
INTO ONE STREAMLINED.
COMPETITIVE APPLICATION AND THAT
IS MUCH.
HARDER THAN IT SOUNDS BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S EXCELLENT
PEOPLE WORKING RIGHT NOW AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING BUT THIS
WOULD.
REALLY MAKE SOME EFFORTS TO AT
TO WORK CLOSELY WITH CITIES AND
THE STATE -- WITH ME TODAY WE
HAVE CHRISTOPHER MARTIN WITH
HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND SOPHIA
REIS WITH BRILLIANT CORNERS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR NUMBERS --
CHRIS MORNING OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA -- ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF AB ONE SIX THE
FLEXIBLE HOUSING PROGRAM.
HOUSING CALIFORNIA IS A
NONPROFIT ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
WITH THE MISSION TO ENSURE THAT
NO ONE IS HOMELESS.
AND EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF
INCOME HAS A SAFE STABLE AND
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO LIVE.
I'M PROUD TO BE HERE TODAY TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE FLEXIBLE
HOUSING PROGRAM AND EXTREMELY
INNOVATIVE.
IN MODEL APPROACH TO AND
HOMELESSNESS.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA FUNDED EIGHTEEN
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AT SIX DIFFERENT
STATE DEPARTMENTS EACH WITH
DIFFERENT GOALS AND POPULATION
TARGETS.
AS A RESULT ONE OF THE MOST
COMMON RESPONSES FROM PROVIDERS
AND RECIPIENTS IN THE
COMMUNITIES STATEWIDE WAS AT OUR
STATE HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS
COULDBE MORE COORDINATED AND
MORE EFFECTIVE FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FILL MULTIPLE APPLICATIONS
REQUIRING DIFFERENT CRITERIA AND
DIFFERENT DEADLINES.
WITH NO CROSS AGENCY OR CROSS
DEPARTMENT COLLABORATION.
MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE ALSO
NOT USING EVIDENCE BASED
INTERVENTIONS WHICH MEANS WE ARE
NOT ACTUALLY ADDRESSING.
THE WE ARE NOT ACTUALLY
DECREASING HOMELESSNESS IN OUR
STATE AT THE RATE AND ADVOCACY
THAT WE COULD.
AS A RESULT.
WE NEARLY THREE HUNDRED A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE LIVE ON OUR STREETS AND
SHELTERS AND CARS OR IN ON
HABITABLE PLACES ON ANY GIVEN
NIGHT.
WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT OUR
STATE'S GOAL SHOULD BE TO END
HOMELESSNESS.
AND WE INSURE.
ENSURE THAT WHEN AT ANYONE
EXPERIENCES A LOSS OF HOUSING IT
IS RARE AND IT IS BRIEF.
WITH THIS NEW FLEXIBLE PROGRAM
THE STATE COULD ACHIEVE THIS
GOAL BY COMBINING SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS PROVEN TO DECREASE
HOMELESSNESS INTO ONE FUNDING.
FOR THIS FUNDING FOR WOULD BE A
ONE STOP SHOP FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
AND CONTINUUM OF CARE TO ACCESS
VIA ONE STREAM STREAMLINED
EDUCATE APPLICATION.
THE POOL IS MEANT TO BE FLEXIBLE
IN EVERY SENSE OF THE WORD
PROVIDING GRANTS TO AND
HOMELESSNESS.
AS THE MEMBER SAID THROUGH
RENTAL ASSISTANCE LANDLORD
INCENTIVES OPERATING SUBSIDIES
SERVICES SYSTEMS IMPROVEMENTS AN
INTERIM INTERVENTIONS.
AND A FLEXIBLE AND EFFECTIVE
FLEXIBLE HOUSING PROGRAM WITH
THESE SERVICES REQUIRES PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP AND LOCAL
COORDINATION TWO THINGS THE
GOVERNOR OUTLINED IN HIS BUDGET
AS GOALS TO HELP AND
HOMELESSNESS.
IN FACT OUR LEGISLATION LAYS OUT
A COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM THAT
WOULD SET INCENTIVIZE.
JOINT APPLICATIONS IN
COMMUNITIES AS OPPOSED TO
PERPETUATING SILOS BETWEEN
CITIES COUNTIES AND CEO SEES
SUCH PARTNERSHIPS AND
COORDINATION ARE CRUCIAL IF WE
ARE TO TRULY MEET THE NEEDS OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
STRUGGLING WITH HOMELESSNESS
INCLUDING SINGLE ADULTS FAMILIES
THE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS PEOPLE EXITING THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IN OLDER
ADULTS.
I WANT TO CLARIFY ONE QUESTION
THAT WE HAVE GOTTEN.
THIS PROGRAM WILL NOT ELIMINATE
THOSE EIGHTEEN PROGRAMS THAT I
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER BECAUSE
THOSE ARE PREVIOUSLY FUNDED
THROUGH ONE TIME FUNDS.
IN CONCLUSION WE ALL KNOW THIS
THE SOLUTION TO AND HOMELESSNESS
IS A HOME WE COMMEND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL.
AS THIS PROGRAM BILLS OFF THE
SUCCESS OF THE FLEXIBLE HOUSING
SUBSIDY POOL IN LOS ANGELES
ADMINISTERED BY BRILLIANT
CORNERS I'M GOING TO PASS IT TO
MY COLLEAGUES OF FEAR RISE FROM
REALLY CORNERS TO SPEAK ABOUT
HOW THAT PROGRAM.
HIS HOUSE OVER SIX THOUSAND
PEOPLE SINCE ITS INCEPTION
BEFORE YOUPROCEED I WANT TO
CATCH THIS MOMENT WITH FIVE
MEMBERS THAT MAKE UP QUORUM ASK
MADAM SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FOR QUORUM. TO HEAR TO
HEAR DEEP HERE THE PIER GABRIEL.
GLORIA.
GLORIA HERE KILEY LEE MONTH.
LIMóN HERE MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK
SILVA HERE THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE
QUORUM PLEASE.
THANKS CHRIS AND AND THANK YOU
SOMETHING MEMBER -- QUIRK SILVA
AND THANKS TO THE CHAIR MEMBERS
I AM SO IF YOU'RE REYES AND
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF THE
FLEXIBLE HOUSING SUBSIDY POOL OF
LA COUNTY.
AT BRILLIANT CORNERS AND ONE IS
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE SUCCESS
OF OUR FLEXIBLE AND HEARD YOUR
SUPPORT.
FOR EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTEEN SO WE
BEGAN IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
WITH EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS OF
SEED MONEY FROM THE LA COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES.
THE CONRAD AND HEALTH AND
FOUNDATION AND COUNTY SUPERVISOR
MARK RIDLEY THOMAS IS OFFICE.
BUT SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
WE'VE EXPANDED EXPONENTIALLY AND
WE NOW HAVE CONTRIBUTIONS.
SEVERAL OTHER COUNTY AGENCIES AS
WELL AS THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND A MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATION.
NOW OUR ANNUAL BUDGET JUST FOR
ONE YEAR IS A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS AND
WE'RE A TRUE POOL OF FUNDING
RESOURCES.
WE HOUSE OVER SIX THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS AND HUGE PART OF
THAT SUCCESS IS THAT WE CAN BE
VERY NIMBLE WITH OUR FUNDING.
THE FLEXIBLE STRUCTURE ALLOWS US
TO IMMEDIATELY ENTER INTO HOMING
IN A HOLDING AGREEMENTS WITH
LANDLORDS AND BEGIN PAYING AS
SOON AS WE FIND APARTMENTS.
WERE ABLE TO PAY FOR WHAT OUR
CLIENTS NEED WHEN THEY NEED IT
TO KEEP THEM HOUSE AND AND
STABLE.
WE ALSO HAVE A SPECIALIZED HUMAN
HOUSING PROFESSIONALS THAT WORK
TO RECRUIT LANDLORD PARTNERS LOS
ANGELES IS COVERING ABOUT 3%
VACANCY ATE SO IT'S AN
INCREDIBLY TIGHT HOUSING MARKET.
BUT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO RECRUIT
NEW LANDLORDS TO ACCEPT THE
SUBSIDY EVERY SINGLE MONTH.
OUR TENDENCY SUPPORT TEAM ALSO
WORKS WITH ANY HOUSING STABILITY
ISSUES WHICH HELPS ENCOURAGE
REPEAT BUSINESS AS WELL.
THROUGH THIS RELATIONSHIP
BUILDING WE'VE EVEN HAD A LITTLE
BIT OF SUCCESS IN CONVINCING
SOME OF OUR LANDLORDS TO CONVERT
THEIR SUBSIDY FROM ONE OF OUR
FLEXIBLE VOUCHERS TO A FEDERAL
VOUCHER.
BY OFFERING SOME INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS AND GUARANTEE THAT ARE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES WILL REMAIN
ON SO WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
LEVERAGE THE FLEX POOL TO
ENCOURAGE -- USE OF FEDERAL
RESOURCES -- TO AS CHRIS SAID
BEFORE ME I THINK WE ALL AGREE
THAT EVERY CALIFORNIAN DESERVES
A PLACE TO CALL HOME THIS IS
SOLUTION IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY
GUARANTEES THAT WE CAN AND
HOMELESSNESS FOR THOUSANDS OF
OUR NEIGHBORS I SEE IT WORK
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THE HOUSING SUBSIDY PROGRAM WILL
CHANGE LIVES AND COMMUNITIES FOR
THE BETTER THANKS.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT SUPPORT
THE BILL.
BRING A WHITE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN
SUPPORT.
ALEX DOORS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES A
CONSORTIUM OF SEVEN NONPROFIT
VETERANS SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
TRANSPORT ORIGIN I VOTE THANK
YOU.
MY SECONDS ALL SOME BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SURE NO REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING WHERE ONE OF THE CO
SPONSOR THE LEGISLATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK.
DEBORAH CARL TO THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
SPRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
DISCUSSION.
THIS ONE I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
YOUR CONTINUED AND DOG ADVOCACY
AROUND THIS ISSUE I THINK WE
WOULD ALL AGREE THAT CREATING --
A MORE COMPREHENSIVE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR FOLKS
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE -- I ALSO
KNOW YOU HAVE A BUDGET REQUEST
IN AND WISH YOU.
WELL ON THAT AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING THAT -- ANY FINAL
COMMENTS YOU LIKE TO MAKE --
AGAIN THE TITLE SAYS IT ALL
BEING FLEXIBLE WITH THE FUNDING
THAT IS AVAILABLE FROM THE STATE
AND EVEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
OFFERS THOSE LOCAL SOLUTIONS
THAT WE AT THE STATE CAN'T
POSSIBLY KNOW WHAT IS.
THE MOST APPROPRIATE FOR EACH
JURISDICTION SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MISTER MISTER MEMBER THE BILL
RATE.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND MADAM CLERK WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ARE.
TOO HIGH CHIU I DATE HI HI
GABRIELLE.
GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
LEE MON.
THE MONTH I MAIENSCHEIN.
QUIRK SILVA AYE HOOKS TO BUY
YOUR BILL WILL BE OUT WILL WAIT
FOR AT ON MEMBERS BEFORE YOU
LEAVE I WANT TO JUST ENTERTAIN A
MOTION FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SECOND MADAME SECRETARY COULD
YOU PLEASE CALL ROLE ON THOSE
ITEMS.
OUR MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH A
RECOMMENDATION ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
OF THOSE ARE BILLS AB ONE FORTY
THREE AB ONE NINETY FIVE A. B.
THREE FORTY NINE AB EIGHT THIRTY
ONE A. B..
NINE FIVE SEVEN A. B. --
SEVENTEEN FORTY FIVE CHIU HI
CHIU I TAPE HI I GABRIELLE
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE KILEY.
LIMA LIMA I MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK
SILVA QUIRK SILVA I THINK THOSE
ITEMS ARE ALSO OUT -- WE WILL
WAIT FOR ADAM MEMBERS FROM THE
CONSENT AGENDA AS WELL.
MS WICKS YOU HAVE BEEN WAITING
PATIENTLY I KNOW YOU HAVE A
NUMBER OF ITEMS IN FRONT OF OUR
COMMITTEE TODAY FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AND FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE SHALL ASSUME YOU'LL TAKE
OUT FILE ITEM THIRTEEN FIRST AB.
SEVEN TWENTY THREE TO FIFTEEN
THIRTY FOUR ALL RIGHT WELL TAKE.
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE A. B..
FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU --
CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- HERE TO
TALK ABOUT HOMELESSNESS.
TURNS OUT WE HAVEN'T SOLVED THAT
PROBLEM YET -- AND I KNOW THE
STATE IS REALLY GRAPPLING WITH
HOW WE TACKLE IT WHAT WE NEED TO
DO THERE'S A VARIETY OF THINGS I
THINK THAT ARE PART OF THE
SOLUTION -- I DON'T HAVE TO
EXPRESS TO YOU ALL THE
CHALLENGES THAT YOU KNOW MUCH
LIKE.
A CHAIRMAN CHIU JUST MENTIONED
IN TERMS OF HIS OWN COMMUNITY
I'VE SEEN A 40% INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS OF MY DISTRICT -- YOU SEE
THE TENT CITIES YOU SEE THE
INVISIBLE HOMELESSNESS -- YOU
SEE SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN -- K.
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS SO WE
HAVE A REAL CHALLENGE HERE --
YOU KNOW IN MANY CITIES THE MOST
COMMONLY PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATA
ON HOMELESSNESS IS THE POINT IN
TIME COUNT WHICH IS BEEN
DISCUSSED AS COMMITTEE AND MANY
TIMES.
I WHICH IS CONDUCTED IN
COORDINATION WITH US DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT.
THESE COUNTS ARE USED BY CITIES
COUNTIES -- GOVERNMENT AGENCIES --
TO DEVELOP SERVICES AROUND AND
TARGET THE HOMELESSNESS
POPULATION -- AND TO COMMUNICATE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOMELESSNESS
TO THE PUBLIC -- WE KNOW THERE
ARE CHALLENGES WITH THESE COUNTS
HOWEVER -- AND THE UNDER COUNTER
HOMELESS POPULATION WHICH THEN
IMPACTS THE SERVICES THAT WE ARE
GONNA -- PROVIDE -- FOR OUR OUR
HOMELESS NEIGHBORS -- AND
FRIENDS -- SO THE LACK OF
CONSISTENT RELIABLE INFORMATION --
DOES PROVIDE A CHALLENGE AND
BASICALLY WHAT MY BILL WOULD DO
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR WOULD BE
TO CREATE.
A STATEWIDE STANDARDIZED FORMAT
FOR REPORTING AT REGULAR
INTERVALS A SPECIFIC DATA ON
HOMELESSNESS ON THE INFORMATION
WOULD INCLUDE THE HOMELESS IS
DEMOGRAPHICS MOBILITY AND
RESOURCE ALLOCATION.
OF THE CURRENT AND PROJECTED
SUPPLY VARIOUS ACCOMMODATION
UNITS FOR HOMELESSNESS AND
HOUSING AND SECURE POPULATIONS.
OF THE NUMBER OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING UNITS
EXTREMELY LOW HOUSING UNITS AND
EMERGENCY SHELTER BEDS WITHIN
EACH COUNTY.
AND THE GOAL IS REALLY TO CREATE
STATEWIDE STANDARDIZED DATA TO
THEN -- INFORM HOPEFULLY A
REGIONAL APPROACH ON
HOMELESSNESS I WOULD BE -- THE
END GOAL YOU KNOW IN MY CITY OF
BERKELEY THEY'RE GRAPPLING WITH
THIS ISSUE SO IS OAKLAND SOS
EMERYVILLE IF WE CAN WORK
REGIONALLY -- AND TO DEAL WITH%
THIS I THINK WEBETTER SHOT IF A
FIXING IT SO -- I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND I WANT TO INTRODUCE OF THE
BAY AREA COUNCIL WHICH HAS BEEN --
OUR SPONSOR ON THIS BILL AND WE
WE WE RECEIVE OTHER SUPPORT FROM
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL BUT
BARRY COUNSELS A SPONSOR.
AB ADRIEN COVERT TO DISCUSS THIS
AS WELL GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EX AND THANK YOU
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK TODAY
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF CREATING
STATEWIDE STANDARDS FOR BASIC
REPORTING DATA ON HOMELESSNESS
AND CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS. TWO WEEKS AGO THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL ECONOMIC INSTITUTE
RELEASED A NEW REPORT WHICH I
HAVE HERE ON HOMELESSNESS IN THE
NINE COUNTY.
BAY AREA BUT THE REPORT REALLY
HAS IMPLICATIONS FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE.
THE REPORT FOUND PRIMARILY THAT
CALIFORNIA LAGS FAR BEHIND OUR
PEER MEASURES IN THE EAST COAST
IN THE MIDWEST AND PROVIDING
SHELTER TO ARE HOMELESS
POPULATIONS EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
SIMILAR OVERALL RATES.
OF HOMELESSNESS AND ON SHELTERED
HOMELESSNESS HAS LED TO HEALTH
AND SAFETY CRISIS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
PRIMARILY THE HOMELESS
THEMSELVES. TO SOLVING THIS
REQUIRE THIS CRISIS IS GOING TO
REQUIRE A FACT BASED
CONVERSATION BASED OFF OF
STANDARDIZED -- AND COMPATIBLE
DATA ACROSS COUNTIES AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY FOUR WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENTTO CREATE
STANDARDS AND DEFINITIONS FOR
THE CREATION OF REGIONAL
HOMELESSNESS MANAGEMENT PLANS.
THOSE PLANS TO BE COMPLETED
EVERY TWO YEARS IN COORDINATION
WITH THE POINT TIME COUNTS.
AND WOULD CREATE APPLES TO
APPLES DATA.
ON VARIOUS -- ELEMENTS OF
DEMOGRAPHIC MOBILITY AND
RESOURCE INFORMATION ON
HOMELESSNESS.
AND WITH THE STANDARDIZED DATA
POLICY MAKERS AND THE PUBLIC
WILL BE BETTER EMPOWERED TO
IDENTIFY REGIONAL TRENDS AND
HOMELESSNESS AND THE SCALE
PUBLIC SERVICES MOST
APPROPRIATELY.
AND EFFECTIVELY AND WITH RESPECT
I REQUEST DRIVE OF LET ME ASK IF
THERE THE MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THAT SUPPORT.
DEMóCRATAS WE GET OUR LEADING
ON TIME BUT WE ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION THANK YOU.
CAN LOS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YEAR
THEM PLEASE SUPPORT ABOUT
LOOKING FOR TO RAISING THE NEEDS
OF YOUTH AND THE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU.
COREY SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND
COMMENTS.
HELLO THANK THE AUTHOR OF THIS
IS A TOPIC WE HAVE DISCUSSED --
AND CERTAINLY TOPIC IN OUR
REGION OF THE BAY AREA BUT ALSO
THROUGHOUT THE STE THE STATE --
WE KNOW THAT ANY INDIVIDUAL CITY
CANNOT SOLVE HOMELESSNESS ALONE
AND WHAT WE'RE OFTEN SEEN IN
MANY CITIES IS EVEN IF HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS.
LEVER ARE PUSHED OUT THEY SIMPLY
AND UP IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
REGION SO -- APPRECIATE ALSO THE
WORK THE PAIR ACCOUNTS ON THIS
AND LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
IT WHEN THERE IS A MOTION.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND
ANY FINAL COMMENTS RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS ARE
TOO HIGH CHIU I DEEP HI.
I GABRIELLE.
GLORIA GLORIA I KILEY
[inaudible]
LEE MON.
LIMóN I MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA.
YOUR FOR VOTES WILL WAIT FOR
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON LET'S GO
TO YOUR NEXT ITEM.
WELL IN.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR --
AND COMMITTEE STAFF AND MEMBERS
I WANT TO FIRST AND FOREMOST SAY
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND ACCEPT THEIR AMENDMENTS.
CALIFORNIA AS WE ALL KNOW IS
EXPERIENCING A HOUSING CRISIS WE
MUST FIND CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
PROTECT OUR RESIDENTS FROM
DISPLACEMENT.
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY BUILDING
MORE HOMES I THINK WE ALL KNOW
WE NEED TO BUILD MORE HOUSING IN
THE STATE -- SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS
OF HOUSING -- AND THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF BILLS -- MANY WHICH
I'M SUPPORTING TO TO ADDRESS
THAT -- BUT WE ALSO THINK MORE
CREATIVELY AROUND ENSURING THAT
WE GET -- AFFORDABLE -- AND LOW
INCOME HOUSING -- YOU KNOW IN
THE BAY AREA THE CITY BILL COMES
BEGAN CONVERTING THEIR EXISTING
RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS INTO
AFFORDABLE UNITS.
AND THIS IS THE BENEFIT OF
PROTECTING RESIDENTS AND THEIR
HOMES AND IS QUICKER AND LESS
EXPENSIVE THAN BUILDING.
AT NEW RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
AT THE BILL THAT I AM OFFERING
HERE.
AND THE CITY OF OAKLAND IS THE
THE SPONSOR OF A SOME IT'LL --
SEVEN TWENTY THREE WOULD PROVIDE
PROPERTY OWNERS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO CONVERT EXISTING BUILDINGS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND SHARDS SIGNIFICANTLY
LAWRENCE IN RETURN FOR A LOW FOR
LOWER OVERALL PROPERTY TAX
LIABILITY -- SO THAT'S THE THE
GOAL OF THE BILL AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND I WANT TO TURN IT OVER.
TO NUCLEAR DELUCA FROM THE CITY
OF OAKLAND TO TESTIFY AS WELL.
IN CHIU AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NICOLO DELUCA HERE MAY
HAVE OPEN MAYOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT ONE I THINK SIMPLY
MEMBER WICKS FOR ALL OF HER
LEADERSHIP WANT TO THANK.
THE STAFF FOR ALL THEIR WORK --
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND AS
RESPECTFULLY AFTER I VOTE THANK
YOU.
SAYS THE MATTER NOT LIKE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS PART.
DEBORAH CARL TO THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
COREY SMITH WITH THE BAY AREA
HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY OPPONENTS THE BILL.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND
I THINK I HEARD YOU SAID YOU
WERE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS WHICH
I GREATLY APPRECIATE -- WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR PUSHING THIS
CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM IT HAS
ALREADY BEEN SUGGEST TO ME --
THAT WE THINK ABOUT THIS AS
MODELS AND OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE AND I KNOW THAT.
YOU'RE REPRESENTING YOUR CITY OF
OAKLAND AND OTHER JURISDICTIONS
REALLY WELL AND PRESERVING AS
MANY UNITS AS WE CANCEL LOOK FOR
TO SUPPORTING THIS WHEN WE HAVE
ENOUGH FOLKS TO TAKE ABOUT.
EIGHT THANKS IN RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'VE A GREAT THANK YOU.
I MOVE THE BILL THIS IS GERMAN
IF YOU WANTED OKAY THERE'S A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL I GUESS
I COULD SECOND IT.
MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
THE TWO OF US.
NOW WHETHER JUST TWO OF US BUT
WE WE ACTUALLY HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND IT SO YOU'LL HAVE TO
VOTES. TO GET A CALL THE MOTION
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU.
HI CHIU I DAVE HI I GABRIELLE.
GLORIA KILEY LEE MON MAIENSCHEIN
QUIRK SILVA.
LET'S TAKE MISS FRIEDMAN.
FILE ITEM TEN AB [inaudible]
SIX SEVENTY WELCOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER TERM
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE YOU IN YOUR
COMMITTEE WORKING WITH US ON
THIS LEGISLATION.
I BELIEVE THAT THE CREATION OF
EIGHTY USES A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR OF SOLVING OUR
HOUSING CRISIS -- IT'S EXACTLY.
ONE OF THE BEST SOLUTIONS TO
GETTING MORE -- HOUSING ONLINE
TO ALSO BRING FAMILIES -- AND
PEOPLE WHO COULDN'T OTHERWISE
AFFORD TO LIVE IN SOME OF OUR
SINGLE FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS INTO
THOSE COMMUNITIES SO THEY CAN
ENJOY SCHOOLS AND RECREATION AND
EVERYTHING THAT OTHER PEOPLE.
ENJOY -- AND WHEN THE STATE
PASSED THEIR LOSS -- THE COURAGE
AND EIGHTY YOU STATEWIDE I DON'T
BELIEVE IT WAS EVER THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTENTION TO ALLOW
SMALL GROUPS OF PROPERTY OWNERS
TO IGNORE THE LAW BUT THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT'S HAPPENED --
THERE'S OVER FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
COMMUNITY IN THE INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE STATE THAT
MAKE UP OVER SIX MILLION TOTAL
HOUSING UNITS WHICH IS ABOUT ONE
QUARTER OF THE STATE'S HOUSING
STOCK.
RESIDENTS IN THESE COMMUNITIES
HAVE OFTEN BEEN DENIED THE
ABILITY TO BUILD A SECOND UNIT
BY H. O. A LOSS OR EACH YEAR IT
TO A RULES DEPRIVING HOMEOWNERS
POTENTIAL RENT.
AND THE COMMUNITY OF IMPORTANT
HOUSING SUPPLY.
THERE ARE MANY INSTANCES OF
HOMEOWNERS WITHIN THOSE H. O. O.
A.'S WANTING TO HAPPY TO USE AND
BEING TOLD THAT THE MUNICIPALITY
IN THE CITY IS FINE WITH IT BUT
THAT THEIR H. AWAY CONTRACTS
PROHIBITED.
AB SIX SEVENTY ALLOWS WERE
APPROPRIATE THOSE HOMEOWNERS WHO
WISH TO SEEK THE DEVELOPMENT OF
A SECOND UNIT. TO HAVE -- ONE IT
APPLIES TO ALL EXISTING
GOVERNING DOCUMENTS AND ALLOWS
REASONABLE RESTRICTIONS
PROVIDING THAT THOSE
RESTRICTIONS ON EFFECTIVELY
PROHIBIT OR UNREASONABLY
RESTRICT.
THE CONSTRUCTION OF A OF AN
EIGHTY YOU WERE JUNIOR ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNIT -- FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO -- LIKE TO THE IDEA OF
PROPERTY RIGHTS THIS IS REALLY
ALLOWING HOMEOWNERS TO ENJOY
THEIR PROPERTY RIGHTS TO THE
EXTENT THAT OTHER HOMEOWNERS ARE
ALLOWED UNDER THE LAW.
IN LIGHT OF OUR STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS CALIFORNIA HAS TO SUPPORT
HOMEOWNERS WHO WANT TO USE THEIR
LAND TO CREATE NOR HAVE MORE
HOUSING TO DO SO.
AND THIS IS A WAY THAT REALLY IS
RESPONSIBLE AND DOESN'T IMPACT
OTHER HOMEOWNERS BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT APARTMENT
BUILDINGS OF COURSE WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT EIGHTY USING
JUNIOR EIGHTY USE.
WITH ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IS
DAVID JONES REPRESENTING THE
TOWN OF TRUCKEE WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
YOUR WITNESS THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBER DAVID JONES ABOUT THE DOW
TRUCK YOU'D LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US TO CRAFT
WHAT WE THINK IS A VERY
REASONABLE BUILT.
AS THE MEMBER MENTIONED A
HOUSING CRISIS IS REACHED EPIC
PROPORTIONS OF THE TOWN OF
TRUCKEE IS UNIQUE IS IT'S GOT
TWENTY FIVE MILES OF NATIONAL
FOREST AROUND IT -- SO IT IS
SEVERELY CONSTRICTED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- AS THE
MEMBER MENTIONED WE HAVE --
HOMEOWNERS COMING TO THE COUNCIL
ASKING TO SEE THEY CAN HAVE AN
EIGHTY YOU OF MANY OF THEM LIVE
IN THE BAY AREA THEY COMMUTE --
THEIR ABSENT FROM THEIR THEIR
PROPERTY DURING THE A SEVERAL
WEEKS THEY WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
SOMEBODY LIVING THERE WATCHING
THEIR HOUSE AND THEIR LOOK
ACROSS THE STREET. FOR
PROPERTIES AT APART IN AGE EIGHT
EIGHT H. O. S. AND THEY HAVE AN
EIGHTY WHEN THEY DON'T -- THIS
WE BELIEVE IS A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH IT ALLOWS HOMEOWNERS
WHO CHOOSE TO NOBODY'S FORCED TO
THE OPTION OF HAVING AN EIGHTY
YOU WE RESPECT THE RIGHTS OF H.
O. A.'S TO HAVE THEIR
RESTRICTIONS WHEN REASONABLE.
FOR INSTANCE IF IT WAS A SENIOR
ONLY -- H. AWAY -- CLEARLY A
SENIORS WOULD BE RESTRICTED FROM
BEING IN THOSE EIGHTY YOU SO.
WE THINK IT STRIKES A REASONABLE
AND PROVIDE APPROPRIATE BALANCE
BETWEEN MAINTAINING THE
CHARACTER OF THE AESTHETICS OF
THE COMMUNITY ALLOWING WHERE
APPROPRIATE -- EIGHTY USED TO BE
BUILT AND CONSTRUCTED WHERE
THOSE HOMEOWNERS WOULD LIKE TO
DO SO AND WITH THAT WE'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AND
ASK FOR MY VOTE.
OTHER SUPPORTERS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ELIZABETH ESPINOSA HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT FOR THE REASONS STATED
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT.
NEVER CARL TO THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
WE ASK IF THERE IS ANY
OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY COMMENTS.
MR.
MY MY MY COMMENT IS THAT I HAVE
MY OWN COMMAND THE AT THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD --
OF B. AS SOMEONE WHO LIVES IN --
IN NAY CHOI I KNOW HOW
PARTICULAR -- MY AGE WE BORE IS
WHAT COMES TO LIKE INSTALLER
INSTALLING SOLAR PANEL -- WHAT
KIND OF PLANTS -- I'M ALLOWED.
TO INFORMATION FOR YOUR HOME.
BUT HOW BUT I DID THINK ABOUT --
TACKLING THE EIGHTY YOU ISSUES --
TO THE H. AWAY SO -- GOOD JOB
HUNDRED WITH THAT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NOT YET.
SOUNDS LIKE THIS MOTIONS ARE
SECOND.
SECOND ALL RIGHT -- EIGHT YOU --
IN YOUR ADVOCACY ON EIGHTY YOU
ISSUES WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
BILLS MOVING FOR TO ENSURE THAT
THIS VERY AFFORDABLE AND DURABLE
FORM OF OF OF HOUSING CREATION
IS SOMETHING WE TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF AND THAT LIKE MY VICE CHAIR --
THIS IS I AGREE THIS IS A
CREATIVE APPROACH AND SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED -- BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE A LOT OF H. WAY
RESTRICTIONS AND THIS IS AN AREA
WE I DON'T THINK WE NEED -- TO
MAKE IT SO OWNERS SO WITH THAT
LET ME ASK IF YOU HAVE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS JUST IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN A IN EACH ALWAYS
AND REPERCUSSIONS FOR MAJOR WAYS
I HIGHLY RECOMMEND THE X. FILES
EPISODE.
THAT FOCUSES AROUND AN H. AWAY
CREATED A MONSTER TO PATROL --
NEIGHBORS THAT ARE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH A TO A
REGULATIONS IT'S WELL WORTH A
WATCH WITH THAT I WOULD REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE THANK THE COMMITTEE.
THERE IS SOMETHING OUT THERE FOR
EVERYTHING.
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MOTION TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN JUDICIARY
CHIU.
HI TWO I DEEP DEEP I GAVE RIO
GLORIA.
KILEY LEE MON.
THE MONEY I MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK
SILVA.
WE WILL WAIT FOR OTHERS TO ADD
ON AND AT THIS TIME WE ARE
WAITING FOR MEMBERS TO PRESENT.
WHEN I WENT TO A PROBATION ABOUT?
YEAH ACTUALLY DO YOU WANNA WELL
LET'S JUST DO A LITTLE WORK --
SO FILE ITEM THREE EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY NINE QUIRK SILVA IS OUR
MOTION.
ALL RIGHT MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION HOW DO PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS
TO BUY CHIU I TAPE AYE AYE
GABRIELLE.
GLORIA KILEY LEE MON.
MON I MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA.
AND FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB TWELVE
NINETY GLORIA MADAM -- IS OUR
MOTION [inaudible]
SECOND.
I'M SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY -- COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TWO BY TWO I DEEP.
I GABRIELLE GLORIA KILEY.
LEE MON LIMóN NINE MAIENSCHEIN
QUIRK SILVA.
MOVING TO FILE I'M TWENTY ONE AB
FORTINO FIVE GLORIA IS OUR
MOTION [inaudible]
I MOVE [inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY -- COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TO BUY CHIU I THE
HI HI GABRIELLE [inaudible]
GLORIA.
KILEY LEE MON WE MONTH I
MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA.
IN ONE FILE ITEM FOR WHICH WE
NEED A MOTION FILE AND TWENTY
FOUR A. B. FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
MOTION.
AS OUR SECOND.
MADAM SECRETARY.
OUR MOTION TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN JUDICIARY. TO
CHIU I DEEP.
DEEP I GABRIELLE GLORIA KILEY
LEE MON.
THE MAN I MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK
SILVA.
HER EIGHT WE HAVE DOCTOR WOULD
FILE ITEM NINE EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- I'D LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE -- AND
STATE A STAFFER WORKING ON THIS
BILL I AGREE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. ONE OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT HOUSING
CHALLENGES PEOPLE FACE TO
SECURING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
OFTEN PEOPLE CAN MEET THE
MONTHLY COST ASSOCIATE WITH
THEIR HOUSING BUT THE LARGE
AMOUNT OF MONEY NEEDED UP FRONT
IS A BARRIER.
THE RISING DEMAND FOR MORE
HOUSING IS COUPLED WITH THE NEED
TO MAKE HOUSING MORE AFFORDABLE.
AND WE KNOW THE RENT AND
CALIFORNIA -- ALREADY CHALLENGES
OUR DEFINITION OF AFFORDABLE.
THE BURDEN OF HIGH RANK COUPLE
WITH OTHER NECESSARY COST OF
LIVING THESE LITTLE INCOME
AVAILABLE FOR MANY TO AFFORD THE
INITIAL MOVING COSTS WITH
SECURING HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA FORTY PROVIDES MORE
TAX INCENTIVES TO HOMEOWNERS IN
THE FORM OF PROPERTY IN MORTGAGE
INTEREST TAX DEDUCTIONS.
THAT IT DOES FOR RENTERS ABOUT
FOURTEEN DOLLARS TO HOMEOWNERS
VERSES ONE DOLLAR FOR RENTERS.
MOVING COSTS SUCH AS SECURITY
DEPOSITS AND FIRST MONTH'S RENT
ASSOCIATE WAS SECURING RENTAL
HOUSING CAN COST THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS.
THAT INDIVIDUAL NEEDS TO HAVE ON
HAND WHICH IS ON A BOARD
UNAFFORDABLE FOR MANY
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
AB FOR THIRTY SEVEN WOULD CREATE
A PROGRAM TO PROVIDE THE MUCH
NEEDED ASSISTANCE TO COVER THESE
MOVING COSTS.
INCREASE HOW THE SECURITY REDUCE
HOMELESS IN OUR HOMELESSNESS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
MAY I ASK A FEW OF SUPPORTERS
THE BILL.
THIS JURY MEMBERS PAUL YOUR OUR
LITTLE DISTRICT LOVE FOR THIS
BILL GREAT BILL ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTIES HUMBLED MENDOCINO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ARE THERE OTHER SUPPORTERS.
HIS OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
MOVING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY DISCUSSION.
OF MR BUT I I MOVE THE BILL
GREAT [inaudible]
IT.
IT WAS MOVED BY THE AMONG BEFORE
SHE LEFT AND SECOND BY BY YOU --
JUST WANT TO APPRECIATE -- THE
AUTHOR FOR MOVING FOR THIS
CREATIVE WAY OF ADDRESSING THE
PLIGHT OF MANY TENANTS WHO DO
NOT HAVE THE UP FRONT CASH THAT
THEY NEED. TO BE ABLE TO GET A
TENDENCY -- THINK THAT THE
CONCEPT OF A LOAN PROGRAM COULD
HELP LOWER SOME OF THE BARRIERS
TO HOUSING -- AND WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU AS THIS GOES
THROUGH THE PROCESS APPRECIATE
TAKING THE MOMENTS ANY FINAL
COMMENTS.
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ALRIGHT MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU HI TO I DEEP.
DEEP I GABRIELLE.
APRIL I GLORIA.
KILEY.
LEE MON.
MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA DOCTOR
WOULD YOU THREE VOTES WE WILL
WAIT OTHER MEMBERS VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
MR LEVINE.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB.
SIX EIGHTY FOUR GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AB SIX EIGHTY FOUR
ACQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION TO
ADOPT BUILDING STANDARDS
REGARDING THE INSTALLATION OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CAPABLE PARKING
SPACES.
AN EXISTING MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
PROJECTS AND NON RESIDENTIAL
BUILDINGS WHEN THOSE BUILDINGS
ARE BEING RECONSTRUCTED IT ALSO
REQUIRES EACH CD TO REVIEW THE
STANDARDS.
EVERY EIGHTEEN MONTHS AND UPDATE
THEM AS NECESSARY WITH ME TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS JULIE
MAIL ASKEY BALL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION HELLO
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
I MISSED YOUR PRESENTATION I
APOLOGIZE JULIE MANAUS GIVE ALL.
WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA LECTER
TRANSPORTATION COALITION I
REALLY JUST WANT TO ADD THAT YOU
KNOW THE STATE HAS SOME PRETTY
AMBITIOUS GOALS FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLE A ENETRATION IN THE
STATE AND OF COURSE THE COMPANY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE THINK YOU KNOW WHEN WE FIRST
DID BUILDING STANDARDS FOR NEW
BUILDINGS WE WOULD GIVE IT A TRY
I LEAVE EXISTING BUILDINGS ALONE.
BUT WE REALLY ARE FALLING BEHIND
THIS GOAL OF PUTTING AS MANY
VI<c.cyan> AND MANY INFRASTRUCTURE</c>
VEHICLE OR MANY CHARGING
STATIONS AS POSSIBLE WE REALLY
HAVE TO TACKLE THE HARDEST TO
TACKLE.
AND THAT'S THE EXISTING
BUILDINGS THIS BILL IS A
REASONABLE APPROACH WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
LET ME ASK OF THE OTHER.
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC TO SUPPORT THE
BILL.
GOOD MORNING WE APPARENTLY ON
BEHALF OF TEST LE IN SUPPORT
THANKS.
HELLO KILLER ROBINSON ON BEHALF
OF THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY DISCUSSION.
MOVE WILL THIS IS HER THEIR
SECOND.
MISSILE BEING CREATE YOU BRING
THIS FORWARD I THINK THIS --
MERRY'S TWO THINGS THAT I
CERTAINLY CARE ABOUT WHICH IS
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE WE HAVE GOOD
BUILDING STANDARDS BUT DO THIS
AND A FUTURE WITH THE CLEAN
VEHICLES AND APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK ON THIS -- YOU WILL
CERTAINLY HAVE MY SUPPORT TODAY --
AND LESSER ANY FINAL COMMENTS
YOU LIKE TO MAKE.
YOUR WORDS SERVICE MY CLOTHES
THERE YOU GO [inaudible]
ADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS. TWO I I
DEEP.
DEEP I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA KILEY THE MON.
MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA.
IF THREE VOTES WE WILL WAIT FOR
OTHER STAT ON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSE THANK YOU.
MISTER TANG.
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- MISTER CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE -- HERE TO PRESENT
EIGHTEEN ARE -- FORTY SIX THIS
IS A FOLLOW UP OF OUR SURPLUS
PUBLIC LAND DEAL THAT I DID IN --
TWENTY FOURTEEN WE CARRY
SOMETHING SIMILAR LAST YEAR
WHICH I GOT ON THIS COMMITTEE.
AND AGAIN WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS TO REINFORCE THE FACT THAT
FOR SURPLUS GOVERNMENT LAND THAT
WE HAVE -- THE FIRST REFUSAL
DOES GO TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS WE HAVE -- CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
WANT TO TRY TO WORK OUT WITH OUR
SPECIAL DISTRICTS -- BUT
RESPECTFULLY.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
OTHER SUPPORTERS THE REAL.
THEY WERE CALLED TO THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
AND ANY OPPOSITION.
MORNING MR MEMBERS FRENCH BOSSY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION WERE
RESPECTFULLY POSE LESS AMENDED
WE APPRECIATE THE OFF THE
AMENDMENTS THE AUTHORS TAKEN SO
FAR.
I WE DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
REMAINING ISSUES FIRST WOULD BE
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL WHICH
WOULD INVALIDATE THE TRANSFERS
OF SURPLUS LAND THAT DID NOT --
FOLLOW THE SURPLUS LAND ACT THAT
WOULD MAKE IT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT FOR US TO BOTH ENSURE
AS WELL AS MARKET OUR LAND.
THAT'S ALSO PUNITIVE ON THE BONA
FIDE PURCHASERS OF THE LAND
ADDITIONALLY I WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE INCLUSION OF
INFORMAL AS WELL AS FORMAL
NEGOTIATIONS IN THE BILL THAT
WOULD.
PRECLUDE USFROM GETTING THE
BEST PRICE FOR OUR LAND AS WELL
AS TALKING TO DEVELOPERS AND
EXPLORING OPTIONS FOR THE SALE
OF OUR LAND.
AND WITH UP TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU.
OTHER MEMBERS OF PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ELIZABETH ESPINOSA AYE
AYE HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA.
AS WELL AS THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA UNFORTUNATELY WE DO
REMAIN IN OPPOSITION TO A. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX CERTAINLY
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAMS A RECENT AMENDMENTS
TO ELIMINATE LEASES FROM
LEGISLATION WHICH WAS.
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC BUT
THERE ARE STILL SOME ONGOING
CONCERN SO WE WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSING HAVING TO DO
WITH LAND USE COMPATIBILITY.
I'M COUNTIES ARE CHARGED WITH
ZONING AND PLANNING FOR VARIOUS
ACTIVITIES AND CERTAINLY THERE
DO EXIST COUNTY LANCE -- THAT
MAY NOT BE SUITABLE FOR HOUSING
SO WE'RE INTERESTED IN PURSUING
A CONTINUE CONVERSATION -- ABOUT
WHICH COUNTY ON PROPERTIES MIGHT
BE SUITABLE -- SO WE'RE NOT.
NOT OPPOSED TO CAN DOING THAT
THAT CONVERSATION -- WE ARE
INTERESTED IN -- CRAFTING
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD PUT US IN A
POSITION WHERE WE ARE MORE
COMFORTABLE AND LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE TO A DISCUSSION WITH
AUTHORS OFFICE THANK YOU SO MUCH
COUNTIES ALSO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
I'M WE AGREE WITH THE CONCERNS
OUTLINED BY CSTA AND ON THE LAND
USE PROVISIONS I DO THINK WE'RE
ALSO OPEN TO HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
HOW DO WE BETTER ALIGN OUR
HOUSING ELEMENT PROCESSES WHERE
WE'RE SAYING HERE ARE VACANT IN
UNDER UTILIZED PLANS THAT MIGHT
BE APPROPRIATE FOR HOUSING AND
THE SURPLUS LANDS ACT -- BUT WE
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A LITTLE
MORE WORK AND HOW WE REFLECT
THAT IN THIS BILL THANK YOU.
SIR BRIDGE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT ALSO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED I WE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH THOSE OF CSTA BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION IF THIS
IS RELATED MR GET.
OF BAKER WAS GERMAN AYE AYES
HAVE A MAYBE A QUESTION FOR OUR
OUR COMMITTEE CONSULTANT --
COMING FROM A SPECIAL DISTRICT
BACKGROUND -- SANITARY WATER
DISTRICT OF DURING MY DAYS -- AT
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WE ALWAYS SET
ASIDE LAND.
THAT -- WE WE KNOW THAT IT IS
FOR FUTURE EXPANSIONS OF FOR
EXAMPLE A AT AT THE LOCAL
SANITATION DISTRICT THERE ARE
THERE ARE LAND WHAT THAT'S
VACANT BUT WE KNOW THAT WE
NEEDED -- TO CREATE.
FUTURE CAPACITY FOR PROCESSING --
DOES THIS BILL [inaudible]
AWAY.
WITH THAT THAT THAT THAT
SAFEGUARD FOR SPECIAL DISTRICT
WHEN THEY KNOW THAT -- YOU KNOW
OF WITH WITH INCREASING
POPULATIONS.
OVER WOULD CAUSE STATISTICALLY
EVEN EVEN SOME AIRPORTS OR SET
UP A SPECIAL DISTRICTS WHERE.
A THE SURPLUS LAND LAND OR IN
PLACE FOR FUTURE EXPANSION AND
ITEM I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT.
THIS BILL DOESN'T TAKE THAT --
THAT ABILITY AWAY FROM SPECIAL
DISTRICT. FOR FUTURE EXPANSION
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE ABLE
TO ADEQUATELY.
A SERVICE ARGUED CONSTITUENTS.
COURTESY AUTHOR IF YOU KNOW THE
ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
ABSOLUTELY SO -- NO FOR FOR
SPECIAL DISTRICTS IN ACTUALLY
TURNER MICHAEL SORRY FOR SPECIAL
DISTRICTS IT ABSOLUTELY DOES.
CONTINUE TO ALLOW.
ANY SPECIAL DISTRICT OR ANY
GOVERNMENT ENTITY TO HOLD LAND
THAT WILL CONTINUE -- TO FOR FOR
OPERATIONS PURPOSES SO I STOPPED
A LITTLE.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
IS WHEN.
THE LAND IS BEING DISPOSED THAT
THE FIRST RIGHT OF REFUSAL GOES
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT -- THAT WAS CODIFIED
INTO LAW IN 2014% TWENTY
FOURTEEN THERE'S BEEN.
NUMEROUS EXAMPLES AT LEAST EVEN
IN THE BAY AREA PROBABLY EVEN
MORE ONCE WE LOOK STATEWIDE BUT
THE CITY OF OAKLAND.
DECIDED TO TRY TO CIRCUMVENT
THAT LAW.
YEARS AFTER THE FACT WITH THE
PRIVATE DEVELOPER THEY DID TO
THE LAWSUIT -- WE HAVE ALSO THE
THE CALTRAIN SITE RIGHT BY THE
HEY WE'RE PARK STATION WHICH IS
AND AND SORT OF THE EAST BAY OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AGAIN THEY ARE WORK EXCLUSIVELY
WITH THE MARKET RATE DEVELOPER
INSTEAD OF WORKING WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER WE
HAVE THE CITY OF BURLINGAME WITH
THE CREATED HEALTH DISTRICT ON
THE SIDE OF A FORMER.
PUBLIC HEALTH BILL WITH THE
PROPOSED TO BUILD A SENIOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING SPACE --
CENTER WITH NO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO SO AGAIN -- WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS JUST AVOID --
DIFFERENT GOVERNMENT ENTITIES
FROM JUST GOING AROUND WHAT WAS
READY CODIFIED AT LAW.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY -- OTHER COMMENTS FROM
COLLEAGUES.
LET ME JUST SAY TWO OF THE
AUTHOR APPRECIATE YOUR CHURCH
YOUR CHAMPIONING OF HOW WE
ENSURE THAT ALL SURPLUS LANDS
ARE USED -- AS WE CAN TO THE
FULLEST EXTENT OF THE LAW I KNOW
THAT THIS IS A BILL THAT'S KAREN
FOR MANY OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OBJECTIVES IN HIS RECENT
EXECUTIVE ORDER -- AND I THINK
IT'S ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE AND
SOMETHING WE SHOULD BE DOING AND
I LOOK FOR TO WAS SUPPORTING
THIS.
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS.
I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ABOUT.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
IS THERE MOTION FOR THE BILL OF
A MOVE THE BILL IS THEIR SECOND.
GERMANS ARE SECOND THE BILL
[inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS TO HI.
HI DAVE NOT VOTING. NINE OR IN.
GABRIEL GABRIEL I GLORIA KILEY
LEE MON MAIENSCHEIN.
MISSION AND BOARDING QUIRK SILVA.
YOUR BILL HAS TWO VOTES AND
WE'LL WAIT FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER TECH.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WAIT FOR
OTHER AUTHORS.
MR MAIENSCHEIN WILL BE
PRESENTING FOR ATWATER GARCIA --
FOR FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB.
TEN TEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA AT TO PRESENT HIS
BILL AB.
TEN TEN AB TEN TEN WOULD ALLOW
DULY CONSTITUTED GOVERNING
BODIES OF A NATIVE AMERICAN
RESERVATION.
RANCHERO TO BECOME -- ELIGIBLE
APPLICANTS TO PARTICIPATE IN
SPECIFIED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROGRAMS.
CALIFORNIA IS THE LARGEST NATIVE
AMERICAN POPULATION IN THE
NATION WITH NEARLY THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
IDENTIFIED IN WHOLE OR PART AS
AMERICAN INDIAN IN THE RATE OF
TRAVEL POVERTY IS MORE THAN
TWICE THAT OF THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION.
AND ONE THIRD OF THESE RESIDENTS
LIVE BELOW THE FEDERAL POVERTY --
LINE.
CALIFORNIA INDIAN TRIBES HAVE
NOT BEEN ELIGIBLE FOR IN
COMPETITIVE FOR MOST STATE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM GRANTS IN
THE PAST.
RECENTLY H. C. D. AS BE GONE
PROPOSING REGULATION CHANGES
INCLUDING TRIBAL ACCESS TO THE
HOME INVESTMENT PARTNERSHIPS
PROGRAM.
WELL TRIBES ARE EXPLICITLY
ELIGIBLE FOR SOME STATE HOUSING
PROGRAMS THE TERMINOLOGY USED TO
REFER TO TRIBES IS INCONSISTENT
AND CONFUSING.
WITH OTHER -- PROGRAMS OMITTING
TRIBES AND TRIBAL ENTITIES AS
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS ALTOGETHER
ADDITIONALLY -- WE DO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
AND THAT HAVE SEVERAL WITNESSES
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY -- AND
IT IS FOR A REASON THESE REASONS
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU LET'S GO TO YOUR
WITNESSES.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN -- CHIU
VICE CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- MY NAME'S AT WHAT
SOUNDS AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION. FOR RURAL
HOUSING WE'VE BEEN AROUND SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND I RURAL CALIFORNIA.
DURING THAT TIME AND ESPECIALLY
THE LAST DECADE WE HAVE ENGAGED
WITH -- TRIBES AND TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES TO HELP -- INCREASE
THE AVAILABILITY OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER --
CALIFORNIA IS THE LARGEST HAS
THE LARGEST POPULATION OF NARAL
NATIVE AMERICANS IN THE IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IS REALLY CRITICAL -- FOR THE
TRAVEL COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
IN A ONE OF THE STRATEGIES THAT
WE HAD LOOKED OUT AND WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEES IS
INCREASING THIS ACCESS. TO STATE.
FUNDING -- FOR TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES TO TAKE CONTROL AND
TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO DEVELOP
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
OF FOR THEIR MEMBERS I WE'VE HAD
SOME LIMITED SUCCESS -- OF ALL
THE PROGRAMS THAT THE TRIBES ARE
ELIGIBLE WE WE'VE RECENTLY HAD.
ONE OH LORD AND THE LAST DECADE --
THAT WENT TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FROM THE HOME -- INVESTMENT.
A AN IMPROVEMENT ACT AND SO WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS BASICALLY --
INCREASES ELIGIBILITY THE
PROGRAMS WERE TRIBES ARE
ELIGIBLE.
AND SORT OF IMPROVES THE
DEFINITION OF TRIBES IN SOME OF
THE CIRCUITOUS ROUTES THAT TRIBE
STATE TO LOOK AT HOW THEY MIGHT
BE ELIGIBLE FOR OUR SOME OF THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS.
SO YOU KNOW TRIBES ARE REFERRED
TO IN DIFFERENT AREAS OF OF THE
CODE -- AS AS MAY BE A SPONSOR
OR DEVELOPER OR A LOCAL HOUSING
ENTITIES SO THIS.
A BILL MAINLY ATTEMPTS TO CLEAN
UP SOME OF THAT LANGUAGE AND
EXTENDS TO A FEW OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT WERE -- AT A MEETING TRIBES
EITHER BY -- JUST MAYOR
OVERSIGHT OR YOU KNOW MAYBE THEY
WEREN'T CONSIDERED AS A
COMMUNITY THAT COULD BENEFIT
FROM THESE FUNDS -- ONE OF THE
OTHER ISSUES THE ELIGIBILITY IS
NOT ONLY -- AN ISSUE BUT ALSO
THE ABILITY TO ACCESS SOME OF
THESE FUNDS ARE STILL SOME
BARRIERS WILL NEED TO WORK OUT
BUT ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT
THIS BILL DOES IS THAT
RECONSTITUTE THE CALIFORNIA NEED
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
AND THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
DIRECT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
TRIBES -- THE STATUTE IS ALREADY
THERE THAT SORT OF ALLOWS --
FOUR EIGHT CD TO DO THIS BUT
THIS AMENDMENT -- DIRAC'S ATD TO
DO THAT IN ORDER TO HELP TRIBES --
ACCESS -- THESE POTENTIAL NEW
FUNDS COMING DOWN TO EVERYBODY.
SO WHAT WERE -- BASICALLY ASKING
FOR IS NOT ONLY CLARIFICATION OF
THIS LANGUAGE.
BUT THE RE CONSTITUTION OF THAT
CALIFORNIAN INSISTENCE A PROGRAM.
THAT TRIES TO GET SOME FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE -- OF THE OVER
HUNDRED TRIBES IN IN CALIFORNIA --
PARKS ME ONLY A 25% OF THEM ONLY
GET LIKE FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
PER YEAR FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS DOESN'T GO VERY FAR IN
CALIFORNIA THE SEARS SO TRIBES
AT THE SAME OVER FIVE SIX SEVEN
YEARS.
IN ORDER TO DO ONE UNIT THAT WE
WOULD JUST LIKE TO GIVE TRIBES
ABILITY TO COMPETE FOR SOME OF
THESE OTHER FUNDS. TO HELP --
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS THAT WERE
EXPERIENCING IN CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
TOGETHER.
SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER -- TO JAMIE THE FAMILY --
HE IS ACTUALLY WORKS THAT
DIRECTLY IN COMMUNITIES AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE AT
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA MEDIAN
HOUSING ASSOCIATION.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE INTERMENT --
MY NAME IS JAMIE NOMINUM I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR NORTHERN
CIRCLING AND HOUSING AUTHORITY.
WE HAVE SEVEN MEMBER TRIBES THAT
ARE PART OF THE CONSORTIUM THAT
WE HAVE THERE -- FIVE IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY AND TWO OVER IN
BUTTE COUNTY.
AND THE PURSUIT OF THIS BILL
WOULD HELP -- IN CAPACITY
BUILDING FOR THE TRIBE SAYS AS
MISTER -- SAMPSON ALLUDED.
TO A LOT OF THE TRIBES ARE SMALL
AND DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
RESOURCES TO PULL FROM.
QUESTION REGARDS -- TO FUNDS TO
BUILD A NEW DEVELOPMENTS BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF REHAB AND
MODERNIZATION WORK THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE ALONG THE SIDE THAT --
BUT ALSO CAPACITY BUILDING AND
UNDERSTANDING -- WHAT'S
AVAILABLE -- WHAT TYPES OF
RESOURCES ARE -- OUT THERE AND
WHAT WE CAN DO TO ASSIST --
OTHER TRIBES HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
WERE A PART OF THE NEVADA
CALIFORNIA INDIAN HOUSING
ASSOCIATION AND SO WE DO A LOT
OF ADVOCACY WORK FOR THE TRIBES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA -- WE ARE A
RECIPIENT OF THE HOME FUNDS WE
WILL BE BUILDING A QUAD PLEX --
IN THE HOPMAN AREA -- BUT THAT'S
JUST -- ONE SUCCESS THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO GET -- AND IN RECENT
YEARS SO WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS
AS A KIND OF AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO MOVE FORWARD AND PROVIDE
THOSE -- AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE TRIBES
THAT WE SERVICE IN THE AREA SO
YOUR CONSIDERATIONS GREATLY
APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS BUYING
ACOSTA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
AND WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
DISCUSSION [inaudible]
MR TIP.
IT'S OUR SECOND.
DISCOVER GREAT -- WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR COMING FOR MR GARCIA --
AND LOOK FOR TO SUPPORTING THIS
BILL APPRECIATE THE MOMENT.
LESTER ANY FINAL COMMENTS MADAM
SECRETARY COULD PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS
TO HI.
HI DAVE.
HI.
I GABRIEL GABRIEL I GLORIA KILEY
LEE MON.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT
[inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
WAIT FOR OTHERS TO READ ON AND
WALLS AWAY FOR THE MEMBERS TO
COME PERCENT
.
BUT A LOT [inaudible]
THE
YEAH THE
THEY'RE TALKING
[inaudible]
LET'S
MR BRO.
FILE ITEM TWENTY AB.
THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AB THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN
AS AMENDED WILL INCREASE ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY
ENCOURAGING FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS TO START A HOMEOWNERSHIP
SAVINGS ACCOUNT.
CALIFORNIA'S CONTRIBUTED TO
THEIR HOMEOWNER SAVING SHIP
ACCOUNT WOULD BENEFIT BY
DEDUCTING THEIR DEPOSITS FROM
THE GROSS INCOME TAX.
IN A REPORT BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AS OF
FEBRUARY THE MEDIAN PRICE OF A
SINGLE FAMILY HOME IN MY HOME
COUNTY OF ORANGE WAS A HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND THERE'S PLACES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE OVER THE PAST DECADE
CALIFORNIA'S HOMEOWNERSHIP RATES
OF THE CLIENT. 53% OF OCCUPIED
UNITS MAKING HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE
SOME OF THE LOWEST IN THE NATION
RESULTING IN MANY POTENTIAL HOME
BUYERS -- HAVING TO RENT FOR
WILL HOUSING IS A ****
DETERMINING FACTOR FOR PEOPLE TO
DECIDE IF THEY STAY IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT.
BY HELPING RENTERS SAVE MONEY TO
MAKE A DOWN PAYMENT HELP WITH
CLOSING COSTS WE CAN MAKE THE
IDEA OF OWNING A HOME IN
CALIFORNIA MORE TANGIBLE WITH ME
TODAY'S JENNIFER'S FACT.
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS.
MISSION WHICH GIVE ME AND
MICHAEL GUNNINGWITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JENNIFER SPECTRUM HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN PRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT OPPORTUNITY FOR
HOMEOWNERSHIP TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE NOTPREVIOUSLY OWNED A HOME.
AND YOU'VE LIKELY BEEN PRICED
OUT OF THE HOUSING MARKET IN
RECENT YEARS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS IDEA GOING FORWARD WE
SUPPORTED IN THE PAST WE THANK
THE MEMBER FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE WHEN RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE OUT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MICHAEL
GUNNING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW OUR THREE THOUSAND
BUILDERS TO DO 90% OF ALL THE
HOMEBUILDING HERE -- WE'VE
CREATED THE HOUSING KILLERS IN
CREATORS LISTEN WE'VE DESIGNATED
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN IS A
HOUSING CREATOR WE THINK THIS
HELPS LEAD TO HOMEOWNERSHIP AND
LEADS TO MORE PRODUCTION AND
HOPEFULLY BEFORE PURCHASING OF
HOUSING AN URGENT AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
ME ASK IF THE OTHER SUPPORTERS
OF THE BILL [inaudible]
RIGHT.
QUESTION WHAT KIND OF THANK YOU
IT DOESN'T MATTER THAT LIKE HAS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JERRY MEMBERS KNEW
ME JOHN WITH MAKE YOU CAPTAIN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MELISSA WARNER MAY
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE OTHER
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT.
OPPOSE THE BILL.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY DISCUSSION.
HAS BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND --
MR ROPER **** YOU'RE BRINGING
THIS FOR I KNOW THIS IS A TOPIC
THAT WE HAVE TRIED TO GRAPPLE
WITH IN THE PAST AND ONE THING I
WILL SAY IS -- THE STATISTICS
ARE -- THAT THE AMOUNT OF TAX --
SUBSIDIES THAT WE PROVIDE TO
HOMEOWNERS ARE MANY MANY TIMES
WHAT WE PROVIDE A RENTERS THAT
BEING SAID I THINK WE ALL AGREE
THAT THE GOAL OF HOMEOWNERSHIP
IS ONE THAT WE WANT TO SUPPORT
AND WANT TO PURSUE WHAT WITH
THAT.
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS HAPPY TO
SUPPORT MOVING THIS CONVERSATION
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE.
ANALYSTS ARE ANY FINAL COMMENTS
I JUST LIKE TO SAY I I SUPPORT
WHAT YOU JUST SAID I'M A CO
AUTHOR AND I ACTUALLY RAN THE
RENTERS TAX CREDIT LAST CYCLE
CELL AYE I AGREE IN BOTH.
BOTH BILLS GREAT -- WITHOUT
APPRECIATE YOUR CLOTHES MATTERS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE AND
REVENUE AND TAXATION.
TWO CHIU HI DAVE HI I GABRIEL.
GLORIA [inaudible]
KILEY.
LIMA.
LIMA NINE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I YOU HAVE FIVE
VOTES WILL WAIT FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS [inaudible]
MS GONZALEZ.
FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN AB.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY THANK YOU --
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I HAVE
NO IDEA WHY I'M IN THIS
COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL.
BUT NONE THE LESS.
WHAT WE WE LIKE WE LIKE TO SEE
YOU SO WELCOME?
WE'RE NOT SO SCARY.
HE IS ALWAYS GOING TO HOUSING
AND NOT TRANCE BUT HERE WE ARE --
I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES A MOMENT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HARD WORK TO HELP
CLARIFY THIS BILL.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY WERE EXTEND
THE DEADLINE FOR SAN DIEGO
ASSOCIATION GOVERNMENTS TO
FINALIZE A NEW TRANSIT REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN BY TWO YEARS
HISTORICALLY SANDBAG HAS BEEN
CRITICIZED FOR NOT PRIORITIZING
INVESTING ENOUGH PUBLIC TRANSIT
BIKE AND PEDESTRIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
OR THE PAST FEW YEARS THOUGH THE
AGENCY HAS GONE THROUGH SOME
DRAMATIC CHANGES.
AS SANDBAG IS NOW READY TO MEET
THEIR OBLIGATIONS HOWEVER IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCE BOARD FINALIZE NEW
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION TARGETS
FOR LOCAL AGENCIES AND INCREASE
THE TWENTY THIRTY FIVE REDUCTION
TARGET FOR ZANTAC FROM 13% 219% --
ONCE IN A BEGAN TO WORK ON THE
UPDATED R. T. P. FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN IT BECAME CLEAR THAT
THE CURRENT CONCEPTS COULDN'T
MEET THE 19% TARGET.
IT'S CRUCIAL THAT WE GET THIS
RIGHT AND SO AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
WELL GIVE US THE TIME TO GET IT
RIGHT AND SO THAT OUR REGION.
RATHER THAN SLAP A BANDAID ON A
PROBLEM AND PRETEND EVERYTHING
WILL BE OKAY SOMETHING SAN DIEGO
IS KNOWN TO DO WHAT WILL NO
LONGER TAKE THAT APPROACH AND
AND SAID.
TAKE THE TIME TO MAKE DRASTIC
CHANGES NEEDED TO DO OUR PART IN
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
EMISSIONS.
RESPECT LAST WHEN I BET. TO YOUR
WITNESSES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
WOMAN GOOD GOOD MORNING TO ALL
OF YOU THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE I'M HERE TO AS A SPONSOR OF
SEVENTEEN THIRTY A JUST SO YOU
KNOW WHAT BOARD COUPLE MONTHS
AGO -- TOOK AN ACTION TO DELAY
THE PLAN FOR TWO YEARS.
I SIMPLY LIKE THAT SIMPLY WOMAN
SAID.
WE HAVE TO DO A TRIED AND WE
HAVE TO BE -- NOT ONLY MEETING
THAT TIME TO GET BUT THE
EXCEEDING THE TOWN.
SO WE NEED THIS TIME TO GO BACK
TO THE DRAWING BOARD AND AND
MAKE SEND YEAH BECAUSE AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW.
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IS BUILT --
FOR THE FUTURE HOW TECHNOLOGY
INCORPORATED INTO THAT.
I WILL ALSO -- AWARE OF THAT THE
HOUSING IS A BIG ISSUE FOR
SANTIAGO SO WE ARE NOT --
DELAYING THE HOUSING REGION ON
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
SO WE'RE GOING TO BE MOVING THAT
FORWARD WE'RE JUST ASKING FOR
THE TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
PORTION TO BE DELAYED FOR TWO
YEARS SO WE CAN.
WORK ON AN AMBITIOUS PLAN AND
WITH THAT WILL BE VERY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR SUPPORT -- OVER THE
BILL.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MORE A TOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO ARE ALSO A CO
SPONSOR ON THIS MEASURE.
THE CITY HAS -- ADOPTED A VERY
AGGRESSIVE CLIMATE ACTION PLAN
OF THE LAST FEW YEARS -- AND
HAVE -- BUT BELIEVE THAT STAND
AG IS HAS TO BE A PARTNER WITH
US IN ORDER TO MEET THOSE
CLIMATE GOALS WE SUPPORTED
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GONZALEZ'S.
REFORM EFFORTS IN THE PAST WE
THINK THEY'RE VITALLY IMPORTANT --
AND THIS BILL -- WHICH SIMPLY
ALLOWED A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME
TO AYE SHE SAID PUT IT GET IT
RIGHT RATHER THAN JUST HARDLY
PUTTING A REPORT OUT -- SO WE
ARE WE THINK THIS MEASURE IS
TIMELY IT'S WE ALSO HAVE.
I'M SIGNIFICANT HOUSING GOALS
THAT WE THINK THIS MIRRORS AND
COMPLIMENTS -- THE THE TIMING AS
WELL AND AND WE ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
ARE THERE OTHER MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT.
MONEY GRAMS ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF CARLSBAD SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION.
MEMBERS MISSED QUIRK SILVA.
I WANT TO ASK.
WHY THEY DECIDED [inaudible]
SOMETIMES [inaudible]
NOW.
I'LL TELL YOU -- AND FROM
PREVIOUS YEARS PEOPLE MAY KNOW
WE WE WE HAD QUITE SOME
CHALLENGES -- AND UPDATING OUR
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
AND GENERAL AND HAD A LOT OF
PROBLEMS AND SO -- AFTER VERY
EXTENSIVE SEARCH FOR FOR NEW
DIRECTOR WEGOT HAS ON WERE ALL
VERY EXCITED ABOUT HIS PLANS AND
MOVING SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND TO
THE ROUND OF AS A REAL
METROPOLITAN AREA.
WITH REAL GOALS IN IN REAL.
CHANGES AND SO.
SORRY BUT NOT SORRY.
WELL I I WILL COMMAND -- SENDEK
ON THAT CHOICE AS I'VE WORKED
EXTENSIVELY WITH WITH MR CRIED A
AND I THINK YOU WILL GET THERE
WITH HIS LEADERSHIP BUT I'M
STILL HIS FAVORITE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
WHAT DID YOU SAY OF COURSE?
HE HAS NOT LEARNED ENOUGH YET
BEING AT SAND ACT HE WILL LEARN
SHORTLY NO DOUBT.
THIS COMMITTEE IS NOT GONNA GET
INVOLVED IN THIS CONVERSATION.
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION A MOVE THE
BILL CERTAINLY.
HAS BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND.
AND ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WELL WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE IN THIS
COMMITTEE GIVEN HOW INEXTRICABLY
LINKED HOUSING A TRANSPORTATION
ARE APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS WHICH I KNOW --
PROCEDURALLY WILL BE FORMALLY
TAKEN A LOCAL GOVERNMENT THERE
IS A MOTION OF DO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY.
CHIU HI TWO I DATE.
I GABRIELLE [inaudible]
GLORIA.
KILEY LEE MON.
WE MONTH I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI.
WITH THAT.
YOUR BILLS OUT OR WAIT FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON AT THIS TIME I
WANT TO MAKE THE ANNOUNCEMENT
THE FILE ITEM ONE AB FIFTY THREE
JONES SAWYER HAS BEEN PULLED.
WE'LL WAIT FOR OTHER MEMBERS
[inaudible]
SURE
.
WHY DON'T WE SEE CONTINUED OUT
ON AS WE ARE MOVING THROUGH THE
AGENDA -- MADAM SECRETARY I'LL
JUST -- ONE WE JUST START SHE
JUST ROLLED IN THE TOP OR DO WE
WANT TO ADD ON OKAY CONSENT
COUNTER.
MADAM SECRETARY THE CONSENT
CONTENT CALENDAR -- GABRIEL
[inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible] EIGHT
ITEM NUMBER -- THREE AB.
ONE THIRTY NINE GABRIELLE
[inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI [inaudible] THREE
ITEM NUMBER -- NINE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEMOND.
I MADE MY I COOK COOK STILL AT
NUMBER NINE AB.
FOUR THREE SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK SILVA.
SUPER I MISTER KILEY WERE DOING
ADD ONS.
AT THIS POINT WAITING FOR OTHER
MEMBERS.
WE'RE DOING ADD ONS IF YOU LIKE
THAT ON ASSEMBLYMEMBER COW IT
KILEY WE ARE NUMBER NINE AB.
FOUR THREE SEVEN FORTY SEVEN
WOULD WHAT.
NOT VOTING FOR A ONE TWO THREE
FOUR AND NO.
THE CHANGE IN A HIGHLY NO --
FOUR FIVE FIVE ONE CENTER.
ON ASSEMBLY.
NUMBER -- ITEM TEN A. B. -- SIX
SEVENTY SEVEN BUT KILEY.
SOME MANY KNOW.
IF YOU TURN YOUR MIKE ON MR
KILEY JUST LITTLE HARD WORK
SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I NINETEEN WE HAVE
ANOTHER AUTHOR.
AND I THINK MISS THREE OF US HAS
TWO ITEMS IN FRONT OF US.
FILE ITEM TO AB.
SIXTY SEVEN AND FILE I'M TWENTY
SIX AB.
SEVENTEEN OH TWO JOINT START
WITH THE EARLIER ITEM AB SIXTY
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN CHECK.
FILE ITEM.
TO AB.
SIXTY SEVEN OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT AB
SXTY SEVEN WHICH IS A RE
INTRODUCTION. TO AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY ONE AUTHORED BY THE CHAIR
LAST YEAR -- IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE CONTINUE THE GOOD WORK OF THE
CHAIR TO ADDRESS THE HOMELESS
CRISIS.
AB SIXTY SEVEN WILL ESTABLISH A
STATE DATABASE TO COMPILE AND
CENTRALIZED DATA FROM STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES ON CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESS POPULATION.
AND THE SERVICES PROVIDED IN USE
BY HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
THIS COMPREHENSIVE DATABASE WILL
ALLOW FOR AN ASSESSMENT OF THE
COST OF HOMELESSNESS TO THE
STATE IDENTIFY GAPS IN SERVICES.
DISCOVER HOW PATTERNS OF SERVICE
USE RELATE TO PATTERNS OF
HOMELESSNESS AND ENHANCE
PLANNING AND POLICY EFFORTS TO
REDUCE HOMELESSNESS.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESS HOMELESSNESS IN THE
COUNTRY IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AN
ESTIMATED A 1-002-900-0900
TWENTY SEVEN PEOPLE EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS.
AND THIS NUMBER CONTINUES TO
INCREASE.
THE STATE DOES ALLOCATE FUNDS TO
THE CONSTRUCTION AND
REHABILITATION OF SHELTERS AND
PERMANENT HOUSING. FOR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES AND
PROVIDES CASH ASSISTANCE MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT HOWEVER MORE WORK
NEEDS TO BE DONE.
IN ORDER TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS
AND THE PUBLIC COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH SUCH EMERGENCY SERVICES
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND
THE NATURE OF ITS HOMELESS
POPULATION.
AND BE ABLE TO EVALUATE WHAT
STRATEGIES WORK -- I'M HAPPY TO
HAVE WITH ME TODAY SHARON REPORT
WITH THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT
OF HOUSING AND OF IN SUPPORT OF
AB.
SIXTY SEVEN GOOD MORNING --
SHERRIN REPORT WITH CORPORATION
FOR SUPPORT OF HOUSING -- UNDER
THE MCKINNEY VENTO ACT WHICH IS
A FEDERAL PROGRAM FUNDING FOR
HOUSING AND SERVICES EXCEPT FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
IS COORDINATED THROUGH
JURISDICTIONS KNOWN AS NAMES OF
CARE.
OR CEO SEES CALIFORNIA HAS FORTY
THREE OF THESE CEO SEES EACH
WITH ITS OWN DATABASE TO TRACK --
CONSUMERS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
RESEARCHERS FIND CONDUCTING
RIGOROUS STATEWIDE ANALYSIS TO
BE DIFFICULT AT BEST WHEN
DETERMINING SERVICE USE PATTERNS
AND NEEDS.
AB SIXTY SEVEN WOULD PROVIDE
CALIFORNIA WITH THE COMPOSITE
PORTRAIT OF CURRENT AND FORMER
HOMELESS.
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
IN THE STATE.
IT WILL WAREHOUSE DATA RELEVANT
TO THE AND TO UNDERSTANDING THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WHOM
KERR COST TO OUR CORRECTIONS.
MEDI CAL CAL WORKS AND CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEMS AND MAKE IT
EASIER TO PREVENT HOMELESSNESS
AMONG PEOPLE EXITING THE SYSTEMS.
A STATEWIDE DATA WAREHOUSE WOULD
MAKE POSSIBLE CONSISTENT
ANALYSIS TO UNDERSTAND BETTER
THAN THE THE STATE'S HOMELESS
POPULATION IN PROGRAMS.
AND TO IDENTIFY BEST PRACTICES
AND OPPORTUNITIES AND SERVING
THE NEEDS OF THE STATE'S
HOMELESS POPULATION.
IT WILL DO SO IN A HOLISTIC
PERSON CENTERED ORIENTATION FOR
THESE REASONS I URGE YOUR AYE
OPPOSED THANK YOU.
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE OTHER
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
CHRIS MARTIN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
AND ANY OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ANY COMMENTS.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
MOVING THIS FOR TODAY I LIKE THE
BILL.
AS SOMEONE WHO HELPED AUTHOR IT
LAST YEAR AND UNFORTUNATELY GOT
STUCK IN SENATOR PROBES BUT MY
HOPE IS A SECOND YEAR WILL BE
THE CHARM -- I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE THE DATA THAT WE NEED TO
ANALYZE.
THE CRISIS THAT WERE END AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
TO MOVE THIS FOR ANY FINAL
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY.
MOTION. TO PASS TO THE COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TO TO I DEEP.
I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY I REALLY MON.
THE MONEY I MAIENSCHEIN.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
YOUR BILL IS OUT.
WHEN I MOVED TO FILE IN TWENTY
SIX AB?
SEVENTEEN OH TWO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS TODAY
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB SEVENTY
NO TO WHICH REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
STAFFING RESOURCES. FOR THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING FINANCING
COUNCIL.
AND ADDS NEW REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO THE COUNCIL.
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ANYA HOMELESS ASSESSMENT REPORT
PRODUCED BY THE US DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT.
ON A SINGLE NIGHT IN CALIFORNIA
OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCED
HOMELESSNESS.
CALIFORNIA ACCOUNTED FOR NEARLY
HALF OF ALL IN SHELTERED PEOPLE
IN THE COUNTRY.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WELL
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
HOMELESS POPULATION ACROSS THE
NATION.
THIS INDICATES THAT WE NEED A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION TO A
GROWING CRISIS.
BOB IN -- TWENTY SEVENTEEN SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY AUTHORED BY
SENATOR HOLLY MITCHELL CREATED
THE COUNCIL TO OVERSEE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF HOUSING FIRST
GUIDELINES AND TO IDENTIFYING
COORDINATE STATE RESOURCES AND
SERVICES. TO PREVENT AND END
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA.
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET BILL.
BOB IT DID PROVIDE THREE
PERMANENT STAFF TO THE COUNCIL
YET THE STATE'S HOMELESSNESS
POPULATION CONTINUES TO GROW.
WE MUST INVEST MORE IN THIS
ENTITY THAT IS TASKED TO RESOLVE
THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS STARTING
WITH THE COUNCIL WHO NEEDS
ADDITIONAL STAFF AND RESOURCES
TO TAKE ON THE TASK.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRES
THEM TO DO.
AB SEVENTEEN OH TWO TAKES THREE
EXISTING PART TIME POSITIONS AT
THE COUNCIL AND MAKES THOSE FULL
TIME POSITIONS AND ADDS AN
ADDITIONAL THREE POSITIONS THE
COUNCIL OR A TOTAL OF SIX NEW
POSITIONS.
FURTHERMORE THE BILL REQUIRES
THE COUNCIL TO PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE WITH THE REPORT ON
STATUTORY CHANGES TO STREAMLINE
THE DELIVERY OF SERVICES AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF HOMELESSNESS.
PROGRAMS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE -- AND I'M HAPPY TO HAVE
WITH ME TODAY JERRY JONES WITH
PROVIDER ALLIANCE TO END
HOMELESSNESS AND CHRIS MARTIN
WITH HOUSING CALIFORNIA TO
SUPPORT AB [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN OH TWO YOUR WITNESS.
THE MORNING TURN MEMBERS --
CHRIS MARTIN WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTEEN OH TO THE HOMELESS
CORNING FINANCING COUNCIL AS
MENTION WAS CREATED IN -- TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND THE COUNCIL
CREE CONSISTS OF NINETEEN
MEMBERS.
THEY WERE TASKED WITH OVERSEEING
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF HOUSING
FIRST GUIDELINES BY JULY FIRST
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS ADMINISTERING
STATE PROGRAMS IN EXISTENCE
PRIOR TO JULY. ONE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ARE REQUIRED TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE COUNCIL TO
REVISE OR ADOPT GUIDELINES AND
REGULATIONS THAT INCORPORATE THE
CORE COMPONENTS OF HOUSING FIRST.
IF THE GUIDELINES.
OF THE EXISTING GUIDELINES AND
REGULATIONS DO NOT ALREADY
INCORPORATE THE CORE COMPONENTS
OF HOUSING FIRST.
BEFORE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
COUNCIL DID NOT HAVE STAFF
DEDICATED SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
DUTIES OF THE COUNCIL AND IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WITH THE PASSAGE
OF THE HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID
PROGRAM.
THE COUNCIL WAS ELEVATED TO THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY AND GIVEN THREE
FULL TIME AND THREE PART TIME
STAFF.
AT A RECENT COUNCIL MEETING THE
THE COUNCIL RELEASED TO THEIR
AMBITIOUS TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN ACTION PLAN WHICH
INCLUDES COLLUDED.
DISTRIBUTING THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF THE HE
PROGRAM DEVELOPING AND
IMPLEMENTING A STATEWIDE
HOMELESS INTEGRATED DATA SYSTEM
DEVELOPING A DATA DRIVEN
EVIDENCE BASED HIGH LEVEL
STRATEGIC PLAN TO STOP THE
GROWTH.
SHELTER IN THE STOP THE GROWTH
SHELTER THE ON SHELTERED AND
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE OVERALL
NUMBERS OF HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA.
CONTINUING THE EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS AS THE INFORMALITY
FIRST.
SETTING GOALS AND DEVELOPING A
WORK PLAN TO IMPLEMENT SB EIGHT
NINE EIGHTEEN THE HOMELESS YOUTH
ACT OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN CREATING
NEW FEDERAL AND STATE
PARTNERSHIPS.
AND DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING
A STATEWIDE PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN TO CHANGE THE NARRATIVE
AROUND HOMELESSNESS.
THE COUNCIL PLAYS A CRITICAL
ROLE IN ENDING HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA AND AS YOU CAN TELL
BY THEIR AMBITIOUS ACTION PLAN
THEY HAVE AN ACT THEY'RE UP FOR
AN ACTIVE YEAR.
IT IS CRITICAL FOR THE COUNCIL
TO BE GIVEN THE ADEQUATE
STAFFING TO MEET THESE AMBITIOUS
GOALS WE MUST STRENGTHEN
STRENGTHEN STRENGTHEN THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING A
FINANCING COUNCILS CAPACITY TO
DO ALL THEIR WORK. FOR ALL THOSE
REASONS HOUSING CALIFORNIA'S
PLACES SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION
AND DRIVER.
I'M JERRY JONES I DIRECT THE
PROVIDER ALLIANCE TO END
HOMELESSNESS WE ARE A COALITION
OF SEVENTY ORGANIZATIONS IN LOS
ANGELES THAT RANGES FROM.
MISSIONS IN SHELTERS TO LARGER.
ORGANIZATIONS COORDINATING THE
PLACEMENT OF FOLKS INTO --
HOUSING -- WHO ARE COMING OFF
THE STREETS TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AGENCIES -- LEGAL SERVICE GROUPS
OF FOLKS ARE BUILDING SUPPORT OF
HOUSING WERE BROAD COALITION WE
SUPPORT.
AB -- SEVENTEEN OH TO WE
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO INCREASE
THE STAFFING AND CAPACITY.
OF THE HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL.
THIS IS I THINK ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT.
MEASURES ON HOMELESSNESS --
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE THIS
SESSION BECAUSE IT DEALS WITH
THE MECHANISM THROUGH WHICH THE
MONEY THAT -- THIS ASSEMBLY IS
GOING TO APPROPRIATE WILL BE
SPENT.
AND IT IS THIS COUNCIL THAT
MOVED.
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN HEAT MONEY THAT -- THE
LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATED LAST
YEAR IT IS THE ENTITY IDENTIFIED
BY THE GOVERNOR -- IN THE
PROPOSED -- STATE BLOCK GRANT
FOR THIS COMING YEAR.
AND IT NEEDS THE THE RESOURCES --
TO IMPLEMENT AND SPEND THAT
MONEY WELL.
OUR CALIFORNIA'S NOT DOING.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO ON THE CRISIS
OF HOMELESSNESS THERE ARE A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE?
WHOSE ONLY CRIME OR CENTER
COMMON BOND IS THE FACT THAT
THEY ARE OUT ON THE STREETS WITH
NO WHERE TO GO.
AND DESPERATELY AND LEGITIMATELY
IN NEED OF HELP.
AND SO -- IT'S GONNA TAKE MORE
MONEY.
AND IT'S PROBABLY GONNA TAKE A
LOT MORE THAN WHAT THE GOVERNOR
PUT INTO HIS BUDGET -- IN
JANUARY WE IF WE AS A PROVIDER
LINES THINK.
THE ASSEMBLY GOT IT RIGHT LAST
YEAR WITH ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS AS A SUGGESTED SPENDING
LEVEL IT WILL ALSO REQUIRE.
INVESTING IN THE COUNCIL THAT'S
GOING TO THEN MAKE SURE THAT
MONEY IS TARGETED TO THE THE
CITIES IN THE CONTINUUM OF CARE.
TO IMPLEMENT THOSE PROGRAMS SO I
COMMEND -- AT THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
FROM THE THIRTY NINTH DISTRICT
I'M PROUD TO SAY I AM -- THAT
SHE IS MY ASSEMBLY WOMAN I I'M
FROM THE SUN VALLEY NEIGHBORHOOD
OF LOS ANGELES.
AND SHE HAD MY VOTE IN HER
ELECTION AND SO I URGE ALL OF
YOU TO GIVE HER YOUR VOTE ON AB.
SEVENTEEN OH TWO THANK YOU.
QUITE A PLUG.
WITH THAT OTHER OTHER SUPPORTERS
OF THIS BILL.
SHARE REPORT WITH CORPORATION
FOR SUPPORT OF HOUSING IN
SUPPORT.
JEFF HEARD AGUIRRE CHAIRMAN CHIU
FOR DEALING HERE IN SACRAMENTO
OF THE HOMELESS.
AND DOING RIGHT NOW THE INDEED
HERE SO WATCHING WHAT'S GOING ON
SO PLEASE YES THIS NEEDS MORE
SUPPORT.
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY DISCUSSION.
HAS BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
PRITCHETT YOUR WORK ON THIS AND
I LOOK FOR TO SUPPORTING IT ANY
FINAL COMMENTS.
THANK YOU -- I REALLY APPRECIATE --
THE SUPPORTERS HERE TODAY AND
AND YOUR WILLINGNESS -- TO
INCREASED RESOURCES FOR THIS
COUNCIL ON TO DO WHAT WE ARE
EXPECTING IT TO DO THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS TO
BUY CHIU HI DAVE.
AYE AYE GABRIELLE.
GABRIEL I GLORIA.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE IN THE MONTH.
THE MONTH I MAIENSCHEIN.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA YOUR BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU SO WITH THAT WE ARE
WAITING FOR OTHER MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CAN [inaudible]
TOM DALY [inaudible]
OUR
AND ONE MOMENT.
CHANGE.
SIX SEVENTY THAT HAS TO DO ONE
VOTE CHANGE FILE ITEM.
FILE ITEM TEN FROM.
NO NOT BETTER
.
HOW IS HE OVER
[inaudible]
GREAT [inaudible]
MR DAILY.
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB [inaudible]
FOR THIRTY FOUR WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE I WE JUST
FINISHED UP.
INSURANCE COMMITTEE HEARING.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO DEVELOP
A SINGLE UNIVERSAL APPLICATION
FORM FOR SEVERAL STATE HOUSING
PROGRAMS -- MY STAFF AND I HAVE
DISCUSSED THE NEED FOR THIS --
HERE IN RECENT MONTHS AND YOUR
STAFF MISTER CHAIR OF BEEN VERY
HELPFUL IN FORMULATING.
THE PROPOSAL -- WE THINK IT
MAKES SENSE WITH THE SO MUCH
ADDITIONAL HOUSING MONEY.
STARTING TO FLOW FROM THE STATE
CAPITOL BECAUSE OF THE HOUSING
BONDS AS WELL AS OTHER BUDGET.
ALLOCATIONS THAT WE HAVE MADE
DâN ARE LIKELY TO MAKE IT'S
TIME.
TO STREAMLINE I ANY PROCESS THAT
WE CAN TO GET THE HOUSING MONEY
OUT INTO THE COMMUNITIES.
AND ADDRESS THE ISSUES SO I
WON'T BELABOR THE THE BENEFITS.
OF A CONSOLIDATED.
SIMPLER MORE COHERENT
APPLICATION.
FORM -- FOR ALL THE VARIOUS
APPLICANTS FOR HOUSING MONEY.
THE BILL.
LET ME ASK IF THERE SUPPORTERS
OF THE BILL.
IS THERE ANY UP.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION IS OUR
SECOND.
MR DALY APPRECIATE -- YOUR WORK
ON THIS -- CERTAINLY I THINK WE
ALL WOULD AGREE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO STREAMLINE THE
APPLICATION PROCESS AND THE
CONCEPT OF UNIVERSAL APPLICATION
I THINK MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
ALSO APPRECIATE THAT YOU TOOK
ARMAMENTS SAID -- THE GOOD WORK
BETWEEN OUR TWO OFFICES AND WITH
THAT HAPPY TO SUPPORT ANY FINAL
COMMENTS IT'S A GREAT
COOPERATIVE EFFORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS TO BUY CHU I DATE
[inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA.
KILEY KILEY IDLY MON
[inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE A TAPE.
THE DAILY YES I THANK YOU YOU
HAVE YOUR VOTES TO GET OUT THANK
YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATED
[inaudible]
MISTER CALDERON.
FILE ITEM SIX AB.
THREE FORTY FOUR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
THREE FORTY FOUR IS A BILL THAT
I'D RAN LAST YEAR THAT I'D WORK
WITH THIS COMMITTEE ON AND AND I
APPRECIATE THAT WORK WERE WERE
RE OFFERING WITH THE NEW.
GOVERNOR SO I THINK THAT THIS
NEW GOVERNOR UNDERSTANDING THE
SITUATION -- IS GOING TO BE MORE
INCLINED TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS IDEA AND AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO THIS IS.
SETTING UP THE NEW BEGINNINGS
PROGRAMME FOR CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS BASICALLY GOING TO FUNCTION
AS A GRANT -- FOR CITIES THAT
WANT TO HAVE ACCESS TO STATE
FUNDS TO HELP -- PUT HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN THEIR CITIES
TO WORK AT OR ABOVE MINIMUM WAGE
AS LONG AS THE PROGRAM MEET
CERTAIN CRITERIA.
BY IN A PARTNERING WITH
DIFFERENT GROUPS TO PROVIDE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES FOR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS -- IT'S IT'S
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN DONE IN
OTHER STATES IT'S BEEN DONE IN
OTHER CITIES HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY
SUCCESSFUL WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN UNDERSTANDING
THE THE DIFFICULTIES THAT WE
FACE WITH THE COST OF HOUSING
AND AND WITH HOMELESSNESS BEING
AT THE LEVEL IT IS.
AND AT THE RATE IT IS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE NEED MORE
OPTIONS ON THE TABLE NOT LESS
OPTIONS ON THE TABLE IN THE
STATE NEEDS TO BE DOING
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN. TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE PROVIDING THOSE MORE --
THOSE THOSE OPTIONS -- AND AND
CUT CONTINUING TO BE CREATIVE
AND INNOVATIVE WITH HOW WE TRY
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE WHICH IS A
SERIOUS ISSUE -- IF THAT WERE
ALL FACING IN EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF OUR DISTRICTS -- AND SO THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE THAT
ARE WILLING AND CAPABLE AND
WANTING -- TO GET A JOB DOING A
CITY SERVICE AT OR ABOVE MINIMUM
WAGE IS A GREAT PROGRAM
SOMETHING THAT HAS SEEN SUCCESS
IN OTHER AREAS AND SO -- WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND WITH ME TESTIFYING
SUPPORT.
IS FRANCINE D. SIANO.
THE PRESIDENT OF C. AND CEO OF
UNITED WAY FOR STANISLAUS COUNTY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
MY NAME IS FRANCINE DC OUT OF
THE PRESIDENCY OF THE UNITED WAY
STANISLAUS COUNTY AND ALSO A
PROUD MEMBER OF THE UNITED WAYS
TO CALIFORNIA.
OUR STATE WIDE NETWORK OF UNITED
WAYS IS PLEASED TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB THREE FORTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MAJORITY LEADER
CALDERON.
WHICH WILL CREATE THE NEW
BEGINNINGS CALIFORNIA GRANT
PROGRAM AS WE ALL KNOW
CALIFORNIA IS IN THE MIDST OF A
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS WITH THE
NATION'S LARGEST HOMELESS
POPULATION.
AN INDICATION OF THIS CRISIS IS
STANISLAUS COUNTY IS AMPLIFIED
BY THE PRELIMINARY RESULTS FROM
A POINT IN TIME ACCOUNT
COMPLETED IN JANUARY.
ARE HOMELESS POPULATION
INCREASED BY NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY INDIVIDUALS THIS YEAR
TOTALING OVER.
NINETEEN HUNDRED UNITED WAYS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA ARE DEEPLY
INVOLVED IN ADDRESSING LOCAL
HOMELESSNESS CHALLENGES.
THE NEW BEGINNINGS GRANT PROGRAM
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TO MOVE
HOMELESS FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS INTO HOUSING AND
FINANCIAL STABILITY.
STANISLAUS COUNTY WE HAVE BEEN
PURSUING A WIDE ARRAY OF
STRATEGIES TO AID THOSE IN NEED
OF HOUSING IN SUPPORT OF
SERVICES.
WE NOW HAVE A TEMPORARY
EMERGENCY OUTDOOR SHELTER WAS
SUPPORT OF SERVICES AND WE ARE
IN THE FINAL STAGES OF PLANNING
AN ACCESS CENTER AND A LOW
BARRIER SHELTER.
IN ADDITION UNITED WAY
STANISLAUS COUNTY IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE CITY MODESTO AND
STANISLAUS COUNTY AND THE
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION.
HAVE FOUND A HUGE WIN AND A
PROGRAM CALLED DOWNTOWN STREETS
TEAM
IT'S MUCH LIKE A BETTER WAY AN
ALBUQUERQUE.
BASED OUT OF SAN JOSE THIS
PROGRAM IS NOW IN THIRTEEN
CALIFORNIA CITIES.
THIS HOMELESS WORK EXPERIENCE
PROGRAM AND POWERS INDIVIDUALS
AND ACTS AS A STEPPING STONE
INTO EMPLOYMENT HOUSING AND A
BETTER LIFE.
IT ALSO BENEFITS THE ENVIRONMENT
AND OUR COMMUNITY BY PROVIDING
CLEAN UP ALONG ALLEYS STREETS
AND OUR DOWNTOWN AREA.
THE PROJECT RECENTLY BEGAN
FEBRUARY ON FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH
AND CURRENTLY THERE ARE THIRTY
FOUR HOMELESS TEAM MEMBERS
INVOLVED AND FIFTEEN ON A
WAITING LIST.
IN A LITTLE OVER TWO MEN'S TEAM
MEMBERS HAVE WORKED OVER THREE
THOUSAND HOURS AND IF COLLECTED
WELL OVER THIRTY THOUSAND POUNDS
OF TRASH.
AND THREE ARE IN THE QUEUE FOR
JOBS. FOR THEIR WORK THEY'RE
PAINTING GIVE CARDS FOR BASIC
NEEDS.
TEAM MEMBERS BILL CONFIDENCE
RECEIVE HOUSING AND JOB
PLACEMENTS COMPLETE RESUMES AND
SET GOALS PLUS THEY RECEIVE MANY
OTHER SUPPORT OF SERVICES.
THERE ARE FIVE TEAM MEMBERS WHO
HAVE TAKEN ON LEADERSHIP ROLES
LAST WEEK I MET RICHARD A
MANAGER AND JACK A LEAD.
THEY WERE VERY PROUD TO TELL ME
ABOUT THEIR WORK.
THE DIRECTOR AT THE MODESTO
PROGRAM SAID THEY ARE INCREDIBLE
LEADERS AND HAVE GONE FROM
HAVING VERY LITTLE MOTIVATION
FOR WORK AND OTHER GOALS. TO BE
HIGHLY MOTIVATED.
SUCCESS ALSO LOOKS LIKE A VET
NAME RAY WHO TOOK TWO WHO HAD
TWENTY PLUS YEARS IN A
MANUFACTURING CAREER.
AFTER GETTING LAID OFF YOU FOUND
MYSELF HOMELESS I WAS NOT AWARE
OF THE RESOURCES THAT WERE
AVAILABLE FOR HOMELESS VETS.
HE STARTED WORKING WITH THE
DOWNTOWN STREET TEAM CASE
MANAGER JUST LAST WEEK HE
RECEIVED A HOUSING VOUCHER AND
DOWNTOWN STREET TEAM IS WORKING
WITH HIM. TO FIND A PARDON.
I'VE SEEN FOR MYSELF FOR MY WORK
IN STANISLAUS COUNTY THE
TRANSFORMATIVE POWER THAT
COMPENSATION FOR A DAY'S WORK
FAIR WAGES INCLUSION AND DIGNITY
HAVE TO BUILD SELF ESTEEM.
I LIVED INDIVIDUALS UP AND OUT
OF POVERTY FURTHER AND PERHAPS
MORE IMPORTANTLY PROGRAMS LIKE
DOWNTOWN STREET TRAIN AND THE
ONES ENVISIONED IN AB.
THREE FORTY FOUR WILL
DEMONSTRATE THE VALUE TO ALL OUR
COMMUNITIES.
UNITED WAY STANISLAUS COUNTY OUR
PARTNERS AT OUR COUNTY WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THE GRANTS OF AB.
THREE FORTY FOUR AB THREE FORTY
FOUR WOULD ALLOW LOCAL
COMMITTEES TO RESPOND
EFFECTIVELY TO THEIR UNIQUE
NEEDS AND TO BUILD ON SUCCESSES
COUNTIES LIKE OURS HAVE
EXPERIENCE WITH DOWNTOWN STREET
TEAM. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
ON A HASSELBLAD ON BEHALF OF
UNITED WAYS OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
ME ASK IF THERE ARE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
AGAIN JEFF TURKEY GEAR
[inaudible]
CLICK ADVOCATE.
CHAU CAR.
I FIRST BECAME AWARE OF THIS
PROGRAM THROUGH THE SAY COG.
AND FINDING OUT DOWN IN THE
BAKERSFIELD AREA HOW THIS ONE
THING I WOULD ENCOURAGE THOSE
GETTING SOME REPORTING BACK SO
THAT.
OTHER PEOPLE KNOW WHAT'S WORKING
AND WHAT IS SUCCEEDING -- MUCH
JUST ME ON THE ACCOUNTABILITY
ASPECT ENCOURAGED THAT BUT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS HEARING AND SEEN
IT WORKING AND KNOWING HERE
WITHIN THIS REGION IT'S BEING
UTILIZED LIKEWISE.
CALTRAIN IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
TO WORK WITH BUT IT'S SOMETHING
OFTEN THAT WILL BE ACCOMPLISHED
ANYWAY THAT'S MY STATEMENT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WEBSITE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ERIC FLOOR
AS ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE FORTY FIVE
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD'S IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- WITH THE STATE
WITH FOUR POINT 2% UNEMPLOYMENT
OUR LOCAL WORKFORCE BOARDS SEE
MORE AND MORE INDIVIDUALS WITH
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT INCLUDING ALMOST AS
WE THINK THAT AN EPIDEMIC OF
THIS PROPORTION.
HOUSING NEEDS A NEWAND UNIQUE
APPROACH THAT AB THREE FORTY
FOUR PROPOSES AND WRAPAROUND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES THAT ARE SO
DESPERATELY NEEDED ARE ON LOCAL
BOARDS WILL ALLOW US TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY SERVE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE SPECIFIED
IN THIS BILL.
THANK YOU -- RESIDENTS ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS WE
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR IN THE
WORK WE DID ON THIS LAST YEAR TO
GET IT INTO A THICK.
GOOD SHAPE AND HOPEFULLY YOU
WILL HAVE A BETTER FATE -- THE
MOVING IT FOR THIS YEAR THAN
WHAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR BUT ALL
THE PAIN SAID.
ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
OUR MOTION WITH THE SPORT
[inaudible]
THEIR SECOND.
COMMENTS FROM THE AUTHOR
SPECTRAL ASTRONAUT VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS CHIU.
HI EIGHT TAPE ARE I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA CUT GLORIA I
KILEY [inaudible]
KILEY MORNING [inaudible]
LEE MON[inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
YOU ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
MR SANTIAGO.
I THINK WITH THE CHAIR SHE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO ON AB -- ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE
I ONE REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT
THIS IS MORE MORE OF A TECHNICAL
FIX -- THE FOR THE LOS ANGELES
AREA -- AS YOU KNOW WHEN -- THE
CHAIR PASSED AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
TWO IT REALLY DID BY RIGHT --
FOR SUPPORT OF HOUSING FOR THE
HOMELESS POPULATION -- WHAT WE
FOUND OUT AFTER PASSING A
MEASURE AGE -- H. H. IN LOS
ANGELES IS THAT.
THE C. C. WAS STREAMLINING
PROCESS DID NOT INCLUDE THOSE
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO SUCH AS A
VOTE FOR THE BOARD TO DO THE
COUNCIL TO DO IT SUCH AS A REAL
ESTATE TRANSACTION SUCH AS A
MONEY TRANSFER.
AND SO WE'RE STILL HELD UP ON
THAT PIECE IN ORDER FOR US TO
DELIVER THESE PROJECTS THAT
BEGIN TO HOUSE HOMELESS -- FOLKS
AT A MORE RAPID PACE WE WANT TO
EXPAND THAT DEFINITION TO
INCLUDE THAT BUT TAKE THOSE
PARTICULAR ACTIONS IN PIECES WE
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
IS ALSO.
AVAILABLE TO THE HE DOLLARS THAT
WE PASSED LAST YEAR -- SO MISTER
CHAIRS BACKLASH FROM I VOTE AND
HAVE A WITNESS YEARS WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORD A. B. ELEVEN
NINETY SEVEN REALLY BILLS ON
LEGISLATION ENACTED BY CHAIRMAN --
TO REGARDING -- BY RIGHT OF
CONSTRUCTION OF THESE PURPOSE
PART OF HOUSING UNITS AMENDMENTS
IN THE ASSEMBLY NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
NARAL AND TARGET THE BILL ON
PROP HHH FUNDED PROJECTS AND THE
ACTIVITY OF TAKING AN ACTION. TO
THE COUNCIL OR THROUGH AN
ORDINANCE TO PROVIDE FUNDING
FROM THE VOTER APPROVED SOURCES
TO FUND THESE PROJECTS -- MAYOR
GARCETTI HAS A BRIDGE HOME
PROGRAM THERE'S BEEN SEVERAL
CHALLENGES AT THE COMMUNITY
LEVEL.
WE'RE WORKING REALLY HARD TO
WORK THROUGH THOSE CHALLENGES
ANYTHING THAT THE STATE CAN DO
TO HELP US.
MEET THE MISSION OF THE ORIGINAL
BILL THAT WAS ENACTED BY THE
CHAIRMAN TO GET THESE UNITS UP
AND RUNNING FASTER -- WE
APPRECIATE AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
GREAT.
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT.
AT A RALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR -- FOR
DOING WHAT WE CAN TO BUILD AS
MUCH HOUSING AS WE CAN
CRITICALLY IN YOUR CITY THAT HAS
BEEN ADDRESSED IN A VERY INTENSE
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING CRISIS --
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS AND LET ME
ASK IF YOU HAVE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE AND FOR WHO REALLY
CARING LANDMARK LEGISLATION THAT
BEGAN THIS CONVERSATION WITH AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY TWO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE ON
THIS.
MADAM SECRETARY COULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS TO HI CHIU HI.
EIGHT TAPE HI I GABRIELLE.
GABRIELLE LIE GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
KILEY I LEE MON [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
SILVER I YOUR BILL IS OUT.
IN THE STREET.
OUR FINAL AUTHOR OF THE DAY IS
MISTER MCCARTY FILE ITEM TWENTY
FIVE AB FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT I'M
GONNA ASK THE SERGEANT TO CALL
MEMBERS SO.
THAT WE CAN HOPEFULLY VOTE ON
ALL ITEMS SHORTLY THEREAFTER MR
MCCARTY.
YET TO WITNESSES MISTER CHAIR.
THREE TWO YEAH OKAY DOUBLE CHECK.
THANK YOU.
YOUR CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
COMMITTEE STAFF AND FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS MEASURE FOR THE PAST.
FEW MONTHS -- AT WITH US IS AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WHICH WILL
INCREASE HOUSING PRODUCTION
CALIFORNIA BY MAKING SURE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PROPERLY PLANNED FOR
HOUSING.
OF COURSE SOMETHING THAT THEY
ALSO BE DOING CURRENTLY AND THIS
IS JUST A SIMPLE.
EQUATION THAT IF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DO NOT PROPERLY A
PLAN FOR HOUSING -- THERE THERE
SHOULD BE A CONSEQUENCE AND
WE'RE GOING TO SUGGEST THAT THEY
NOT SUGGEST OUTLINING THE RISK
LOSING ACCESS TO CERTAIN STATE
GRANTS AFTER A FIVE YEAR PERIOD
SO WE'LL GIVE THEM FIVE YEARS.
TO MAKE SURE THE COMPLY WITH A
HOUSING ELEMENT LONG YOU KNOW
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF A OF A
HOUSING CRISIS WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE ALL LOCAL GOVERNMENT STEP
UP TO ADEQUATELY.
PLAN FOR HOUSING A MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING TRADITIONAL -- SINGLE
FAMILY HOUSING WE NEED EVERYBODY
STEP UP TO THE PLATE AND THIS
BILL BUILDS AWFULLY IMPORTANT
STEPS HAVE BEEN TAKEN LAST FOR
YEARS TO STRENGTHENS CALIFORNIA.
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW.
AGAIN THIS BILL STATES BEGINNING
A TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND AGAIN
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO BECAUSE
THE DRAFTING ISSUES WE WEREN'T
ABLE TO CLARIFY THIS HERE BUT
WE'LL DO THIS COULD GOING
FORWARD.
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
WE WILL REMOVE ELIGIBILITY FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO APPLY FOR
CERTAIN STATE GRANTS IF THEY ARE
NOT COMPLYING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING ELEMENTS --
THEIR PLACES IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
IT'S EASIER TO BUILD HOUSING IN
SOME PLACES WHERE IT'S MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT CERTAINLY CERTAINLY
VERY DIFFICULT IF THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION IS NOT --
ADEQUATELY AS OWNING LAND -- FOR
FOR HOUSING UNDER THE HOUSING
ELEMENT AT THE LA L. AS
IDENTIFIED LOCAL RESISTANCE AND
HOUSING PRODUCTION AS THE SINGLE
MOST IMPORTANT FACTOR WHETHER OR
NOT A CITY HAS REACHED ITS
HOUSING GOALS -- CERTAINLY THEY
PLAY A LOCAL -- AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN MAKING SURE THAT WE
ADDRESS.
A HOUSING ISSUES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS BILL INCENTIVIZE
JURISDICTIONS TO DO WHAT THEY
FRANKLY SHOULD BE DOING ANYWAY
IT'S NOT A SILVER BULLET BUT WE
THINK WILL INCREASE HOUSING
PRODUCTION.
BY FOCUSING ON INCENTIVE FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DO THE
RIGHT THING AND PLAN FOR HOUSING
AND AGAIN THIS IS ABOUT FAIRNESS
AND EQUITY.
THE MAJORITY OF CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE STEPPING UP WHEN
IT COMES.
TO HOUSING THE HOUSING ELEMENT
UNFORTUNATELY CERTAIN
JURISDICTIONS ARE NOT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE FOCUS ON
ACCOUNTABILITY I WITH ME OUR
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS JENNIFER SPECT.
AND THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION DEBORAH CARLTON
[inaudible]
YOUR WITNESSES.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER
SPECK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS A BABY.
FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT SAY ARE
ALONG WITH OTHER HOUSING GROUPS
HAVE LONG ADVOCATED FOR A STICK
TO BE ESTABLISHED IN STATE LAW
THAT WILL HOLD LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR PLANNING. FOR
THE NECESSARY HOUSING TO TAKE
CARE OF OUR STATE'S POPULATION.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
SPECIFICALLY BILLS ON STATE
PLANNING GOALS ESTABLISHED IN SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE WHICH WAS AN
ACCIDENT TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
WHICH LINKS TRANSPORTATION AND
HOUSING TOGETHER. FOR PLANNING
PURPOSES IT'S ALSO BUILT ON THE
LEGISLATURE'S TWENTY SEVENTEEN
HOUSING PACKAGE.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT ONE SET
OF EYES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO A
PURPLE PLAN FOR HOUSING AND WE
BELIEVE WILL EVENTUALLY REDUCE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED BY
INCENTIVIZING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO PROPERLY PLAN FOR HOUSING --
WHERE OUR STATE NEEDS IT MOST WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE VOTE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE?
THANK YOU DEMOCRATS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
QUITE FRANKLY THE AUTHOR IN
MISTAKE AS SAID IT ALL SO I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
HI GOOD MORNING MICHELLE PARRIS
SAID -- WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES I
AM VERY EXCITED TO BE ON THE
SIDE OF THE TABLE WITH THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION REALLY.
HAPPEN SO OFTEN OF SO MY
ORGANIZATION -- FOCUSES ITS WORK
IN A IN IN PART IN HOUSING
JUSTICE THAT'S A MAJOR COMPONENT
WHAT WE DO. TO ADVANCE THE
RIGHTS OF FAMILIES TO LIVE IN
COMMUNITIES WITH GOOD JOBS AND
GOOD SCHOOLS AND GOOD SERVICE AS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR ETHNICITY OR
INCOME -- I DON'T THINK ANY TO
EXPLAIN THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS ANYONE ON THIS COMMITTEE --
WE DIDN'T GET INTO THIS CRISIS
ONE WAY IT WAS A LOT OF
DECISIONS AND MARKET MECHANISMS
THAT GOT US HERE AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE ONE WAY THAT WE GET
OUT WE NEED A LOT OF TOOLS.
AND A LOT OF POLICIES TO FIX
THIS AND I THINK AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT CAN BE ONE OF THOSE
TOOLS -- SIMPLY PUT FIFTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT RECONDITION CERTAIN
STATE GRANT FUNDS TO
JURISDICTIONS CONTINGENT ON
HAVING A COMPLAINT HOUSING
ELEMENT -- CONDITIONING FUNDS
THAT -- RECALCITRANT
JURISDICTIONS WANT WILL HELP
BRING THEM INTO COMPLIANCE.
PUBLIC ADVOCATES HELPED CREATE
THE WHEN BAY AREA GRANT PROGRAM
IN DC AREA MEMBERS MAY BE
FAMILIAR WITH THAT.
BUT LIKE AB FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
THIS PROGRAM CONDITION CERTAIN
FUNDS BASED ON LOCAL JUST
JURISDICTIONS ADVANCING THE BAY
AREA'S LAND USE AND HOUSING
GOALS.
AND JURISDICTIONS MUST MEET
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING
HAVING A COMPLIANT HOUSING
ELEMENT TO QUALIFY.
BEFORE -- BAG.
OVER TWENTY JURISDICTIONS IN THE
BAY AREA DIDN'T HAVE COMPLAINED
HOUSING ELEMENTS AND NOW NEARLY
ALL OF THEM DO.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS CREATED MANY
CARROTS TO ENCOURAGE
JURISDICTIONS TO DO THE RIGHT
THING ON HOUSING BUT SO FAR
CARROTS HAVE NOT BEEN ENOUGH TO
GET SOME JURISDICTIONS TO ACT.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WOULD NOT
TAKE EFFECT UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE AND THIS GIVES
JURISDICTIONS PLENTY OF TIME TO
DO THE RIGHT THING.
COMEDY COMPLIANCE AND WITH THE
STICK THANK YOU.
ME ASK IF THERE THE MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
CHAIRMAN CHIU.
KEVIN -- I CONSIDER THE SMART
LEGISLATION WATCHING OVER THE
VARIOUS YEARS.
YES WE HAVE SOME FUN OUTSIDE --
ANYWAY -- BUT ANYWAY -- DEALING
WITH THIS I THINK IT'S GOOD
LEGISLATION BECAUSE INDEED THE
SHOULD WE SAY STICK IS OUT THERE
TO WHAT AND THE REASONS WHY --
IN THE PAST YOU'VE NOT SEEN THIS
AND I BELIEVE I KNOW I'M NOT
VERY OFTEN AGREEMENT WITH THE
TRADE IN THE ASSOCIATION -- I
BELIEVE IT'S A GOOD EFFORT TO
DEAL WITH THE UNDER -- THOUSAND
SHOULD WE SEE DOLLAR RENTING
ISSUE.
AND HOLDS THE STE.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHRIS LEE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES -- RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION THE BILL HAS TAKEN
SORT OF AN INTERESTING PATH WE
WENT FROM A VERY NARROWLY
DEFINED STICK AS REGIONAL SAY.
AND I'M A BIG TRIGGER THAT WOULD
LIKELY WOULD HAVE CAUGHT UP
NEARLY ALL JURISDICTIONS WE NOW
SORT OF FLIP THAT AND WE HAVE
EVEN INCREDIBLY BROAD STACK
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ALL
POTENTIAL STATE GRANT FUNDS.
WITH A VERY NARROW EXCEPTION FOR
CERTAIN TRANSPORTATION RELATED
GRANTS AND CERTAIN HOUSING
ELEMENT RELATED GRANTS AND SO
THE ANTI HAS REALLY BEEN UP TO
IN TERMS OF IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SERVICES THAT COUNTIES PROVIDE.
FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WATER
SEWER INFRASTRUCTURE CAP AND
TRADE AGRICULTURAL SERVICES WE
NOW HAVE A BILL THAT'S
INCREDIBLY BROAD IN TERMS OF THE
POTENTIAL FUNDING THAT COULD BE
WITHHELD FROM LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
AND SO THAT'S OBVIOUSLY A
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN FOR COUNTIES
ON THE OTHER HAND WE'VE MOVED
FROM A STANDARD THAT WE DIDN'T%
THINK VERY MANY JURISDICTIONS
WOULD BE ABLE TO FEASIBLY MEET
GIVEN OUR EXISTING FUNDING
SHORTAGE. FOR BELOW MODERATE
INCOME HOUSING -- AFFORDABLE TO
LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS IN
CALIFORNIA AND NOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE STANDARDS FROM AB --
SEVENTY TWO SEES ACTED NOT
OBJECT TO AB SEVENTY TWO WE DID
REQUEST SOME AMENDMENTS TO
INCREASE THE DUE PROCESS
PROVISIONS INHERENT IN AB --
SEVENTY TWO AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S A SPECIALLY
NEEDED IN THIS BILL NOW BECAUSE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RATHER THAN
HAVING A PROCESS WHERE EACH CD
IS GOING TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
AND POTENTIALLY REFERRED
JURISDICTIONS TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL -- WE'RE NOT LEAVING UP
TO THAT SAME ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESS A REALLY MUCH STRONGER
REMEDY WHICH IS WITHHOLDING THE
ABILITY TO APPLY FOR ALL STATE
GRANTS I'M WE DO HAVE A SPECIFIC
CONCERN WITH THE FACT THAT THE
BILL DOES NOT INCLUDE A
DEFINITION OF THE STATE GRANT.
AS YOU KNOW COUNTIES PROVIDE A
HUGE NUMBER OF THE STATE LEVEL
SERVICES ESPECIALLY IN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES STATE.
I'M A SPACE SO WE ESPECIALLY
NEED TO CLARIFY THAT THE BILL
DOESN'T APPLY TO ANYTHING IN
REALIGNMENT THERE'S SOME
LANGUAGE IN THERE ABOUT
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
REVENUES -- SOME REVENUES IN
REALIGNMENT ARE CONSTITUTIONALLY
PROTECTED OTHERS ARE NOT AND SO
IF WE'RE GOING TO PUT YOU KNOW
OUR IMPLEMENTATION OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS.
AT RISK -- THAT IS A HUGE
CONCERN FOR US -- FINALLY ON THE
DUE PROCESS PIECE I I REALLY
THINK THAT SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE LOOKED AT IN THIS BILL
BECAUSE TWO OF THE ELEMENTS.
IN THAT SUBDIVISION J. THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT IN
THE DENSITY BONUS LAW REALLY ARE
MOVING TARGETS ALL RIGHT --
THERE'S PROPOSALS TO AMEND IN
CITY BONUS NEARLY EVERY YEAR
THERE'S BILLS THAT NEARLY WENT
INTO EFFECT LAST YEAR THERE'S
MORE UNDER CONSIDERATION THIS
YEAR.
AND SO THE RISK OF ACCIDENTAL
NON COMPLIANCE -- INCREASES WITH
EACH LEGISLATIVE CHANGE THERE
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS I SEE
SECONDS RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ROBINSON WAS SHOT YOUR AND WE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION -- WE WERE OPPOSED
TO THE INITIAL VERSION OF THIS
BILL WHICH ATTEMPTED -- TO THIS
HOLD THE FLOW TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING TO JURISDICTIONS THAT
WERE FOUND TO BE IN COMPLIANCE --
WE STILL REMAIN CONCERNED WITH
THE BILL I DO SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SUCH AS THE
PROHIBITION ON THE ACCESS TO CAP
AND TRADE GRANTS ARE AGENCIES --
ARE ARE WELL FUNDED FROM A
PROGRAM KNOWN AS THE TRANSIT
INTERCITY REAL CAPITAL PROGRAM
WHICH FUNDS TRANSITIVE PERMITS
UP AND DOWN THE STATE --
INCLUDING STATION AREA
DEVELOPMENT -- STATION
DEVELOPMENT GRADE SEPARATIONS
ELECTRIC BUSES EXCITE OR EXCEL --
AND WE THINK FRANKLY LIMITING
ACCESS TO THAT PART OF FUNDING
TO CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT IN
SOME CASES DO RUN TRANSIT
SERVICE OR ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THOSE STATIONS AND GRADE
SEPARATIONS -- FLIES IN THE FACE
OF THE GOALS OF THIS STATE HAS
SET THE POLICY GOALS OF STATUS
AT TO BUILD MORE TRANSIT AND
HOUSING.
OR I SHOULD SAY BILL TRANSIT
CLOSER TO HOUSING AND AND VICE
VERSA SO WE WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THAT CONCERN SEE IF THERE'S A
WAY. TO ALSO EXCLUDE -- THOSE
TYPES OF TRANSPORTATION GRANTS
THAT ARE SO IMPORTANT TO THOSE
PROJECTS MOVING FORWARD THANK
YOU.
OTHER OPPOSITION I BELIEVE IF
ONE DOES HEAR BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS A
CALIFORNIA WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE AMENDMENTS THAT
THEY'VE TAKEN THUS FAR BUT WE DO
ALSO SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS
THAT WERE OUTLINED.
BY MISTER ROBINSON AND AND
MISTER LEE -- IN THE GRANT
FUNDING THAT IS OFTEN BLENDED
WITH LOCAL REVENUES FOR PROJECTS
AND THE CONTRACTORS WOULD
OBVIOUSLY BE ABLE WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO BUILD AS MUCH AND SO
IT'S A CONCERN SO.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR FOR
THE WORK THUS FAR.
MISTER MEMBERS DAVID JOHNSON
HALF THE CITIES OF GLENDALE IN
THE CITY'S MARIN WE SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF A C. SACK PRICKLY
WITH DENSITY BONUS A LAW
CHANGING.
AND THE POTENTIAL LIABILITY LACK
OF DUE PROCESS SO.
WE WOULD ASK FOR AN OF A LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE --
LET ME JUST FIRST BY THANK START
BY THANKING THE AUTHOR FOR YOUR
DEEP GAUGE BUT WITH OUR
COMMITTEE ON THIS I KNOW YOU
STARTED WITH A PROPOSAL -- THAT
AT PROPOSED TINE SP ONE
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING TO
HOUSING PRODUCTION AND THAT WAS
A CONCEPT I WAS OPEN TO BUT
CERTAINLY HEARD A LOT OF
FEEDBACK -- THROUGHOUT -- ARE
LEGISLATURE ON THAT TOPIC AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS AND
FLEXIBILITY TO MOVE TOWARD.
THIS NEW CONCEPT OF FOCUSING ON
ON STATE GRANTS ONE THING I
WOULD JUST MENTION AS I THINK
IT'S CLEAR AND WE HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING -- WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO REFINE THE DEFINITION OF
WHAT THAT MEANS THROUGH THIS
PROCESS BUT I THINK THE CONCEPT
IS -- ONE THAT I CAN CERTAINLY
SUPPORT -- AS A WAY OF OF OF OF
MAKING SURE THAT CITIES DO THE
RIGHT THING SO -- VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT WE'VE DONE ON THIS TOGETHER
LET ME ASK IF THERE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT WOULD LIKE.
TO HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MISTER GLORIA.
JUST A QUICK COMMENT VERY ATTEND
THE COMMENTS YOU MADE AS
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK IN HELPING
GUIDE THE AUTHOR.
AND AUTHORS WILLINGNESS TO TO
WALK TO REFINE THIS PARTICULAR
MEASURE I THINK -- IN THE
CONTEXT WHEN WE HEARD THIS I
THINK IS AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM
RELEASED THE CONCEPT OF IT.
COMMITTEE DID NOT RESPOND WELL
TO THAT WE SHOULD BE AUTHOR
TAKING THAT IN A FEW GUYS
RELATES TO GAS TAX.
AND THE VOTERS RECENT ACTION I
THINK A LOT OF US US A LOT OF
TIME TRYING TO FEND THE ACTION
OF THE LEGISLATURE PROMISING THE
COMMITTEES WOULD BENEFIT FROM
THOSE FUNDS.
TAKING THOSE OFF THE TABLE WOULD
HAVE BEEN ACCEPTABLE TO THIS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- BUT THE
APPROACH CURRENTLY IN TALKING
ABOUT SOME OF THESE -- MORE
PERFORMANCE BASED GRANTS OR OR
MORE ELECTED GRANTS -- I THINK A
IS IS MORE OF THE RIGHT LINE YOU
RAISE ISSUES THAT NEED CONTINUE
DISCUSSION I TRUST MR MCCARTY
WILL DO PRECISELY THAT -- BUT
ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW COMMIT
CITIES LIKE MY WHICH I KNOW I
DON'T BELIEVE ALL OF MY CITIES
OF MY DISTRICT ARE MEETING THEIR
HOUSING PRODUCTION GOALS.
SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THOSE THAT ARE TRYING THEY NEED
TO SEE SOME SORT OF BENEFIT FROM
THAT WHICH I THINK IS THE NATURE.
OF THE BILL SO -- AGAIN I
APPRECIATION TO MISTER MCCARTY
FOR LISTENING TO THE PREVIOUS AT
COMMITTEE HEARINGS COMMENTS
ADJUSTING ACCORDINGLY NIGHT --
HOPE THAT YOU CONTINUE TO THE
PRODUCT THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
REFINING THIS EVEN FURTHER AGAIN
TO INCENTIVIZE COMMITTEE STEP UP
FOR THE HOUSING RELATED
RESPONSIBILITIES AND HOLDING
THOSE THAT DON'T ACCOUNTABLE --
BY PROHIBITING THEIR ABILITY TO
COMPETE FOR THESE -- PRECIOUS
AND FIND IT FUNDS THANK OU.
MS IMAN.
THANK YOU I WANT TO ECHO -- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO'S
COMMENTS AT PARTICULARLY AS THEY
DO HAVE A A CITY THAT IS ON THE
LIST -- I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION AND
CERTAINLY -- I WILL I SUPPORTED
IT TO DATE I I AM WATCHING HOW
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD WHAT I
DON'T WANT TO DO IS I DON'T WANT.
TO PUT THE THE ALL ARE PUT
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE STRUGGLING
TO MEET.
I NEEDED A GOAL THAT WE I THINK
ALL AGREE ON WE WE WE WE
ABSOLUTELY RECOGNIZE THAT WE
NEED MORE HOUSING BUT I DON'T
WANT TO PUT THOSE SAME
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE STRUGGLING --
IN A POSITION WHERE SOME OF THE
OTHER FUNDS WOULD HELP THEM.
MOVE FORWARD IN A WAY THAT THE
CITY -- NEEDS AND SO I THINK
THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE THE THE
CHALLENGES THAT I'M HAVING IN
TRYING TO THINK WE'LL THERE'S
ALL THESE FUNDS ARE FINE AT AND
I CERTAINLY DON'T WANT THEM. TO
BE PUT IN A POSITION WHERE NOW
NOT ONLY CAN THEY NOT MEET AT
THEIR HOUSING NEED OR ARE THEY
STRUGGLING TO MEET THEIR NEEDS
BUT THEY'RE ALSO HAVING OTHER
ISSUES AND OTHER -- AREAS THAT
THE CITY NEEDS TO BE HEALTHY
CITY SO -- I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT I APPRECIATE THAT
CITIES AB ONE HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED THEY'VE BEEN.
YOU KNOW THEY KNOW THAT IF
THEY'RE ON THE LIST OR NOT BUT
ALSO AB AND THAT.
WE ARE GIVING THEM AT LEAST FIVE
YEARS TO REACH THAT I WOULD HOPE
THAT IF A CITY FOR WHATEVER
REASON -- THAT FOUND THAT FIVE
YEAR AT DIFFICULT THAT THERE
COULD BE SOME THOUGHT ABOUT IT
NOT ALL CITIES ARE THE SAME CITY
I HAD IS A RURAL CITY -- EIGHT
IT'S DIFFERENT IT'S SMALL --
AIDS IT'S JUST DIFFERENT AND
SOME THINGS CAN'T HAPPEN IN THE
SAME WAY THAT THEY DO -- IN
SUBURBAN OUR METROPOLITAN AREAS
SO JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THAT WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY.
MISS QUIRK SILVA.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR I HAD
WE HAVE -- DISCUSS THIS BILL AND
THERE ARE SCENARIOS WITH THE
BILL THAT I COMPLETELY SUPPORT
BUT AS MEN NOTED SOME -- ISSUES
WITH KIND OF THE CARROT AND THE
STICK HERE BUT TODAY.
ORANGE COUNTY RELEASED -- THEIR
POINT IN TIME COUNTY EVEN THOUGH
WE KNEW THAT THEY HAD TAKEN IT
BEFORE AND THERE HAD BEEN OTHER
COUNTS.
WHERE SIX THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
PEOPLE IN ORANGE COUNTY ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS?
AND AS SOME OF YOU HAVE HEARD
BEFORE I'VE SAID THIS NUMEROUS
TIMES IT IS JUST.
UNACCEPTABLE THAT WE HAVE A
COUNTIES AND CITIES -- THAT MANY
TIMES HAVE THE RESOURCES BUT ARE
CHOOSING NOT TO MOVE FORWARD
WHETHER IT BE WITH -- PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WHETHER IT BE --
THEY'RE JUST SAYING NO.
AND IN ORANGE COUNTY BECAUSE WE
HAPPEN TO HAVE A FEDERAL JUDGE
JUDGE DAVID CARTER WHO IS SAID
NO THIS IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN
WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE A
THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE.
ON A RIVER BED FOR TWO YEARS AND
YOU'RE GOING TO DO YOUR JOBS.
THAT IS IT MELTED TOO MANY
CITIES IN ORANGE COUNTY MOVING
FORWARD EMERGENCY HOUSING PLANS --
FUTURE SUPPORTIVE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND IT'S
GETTING TO THE TABLE TO TO LOOK
AT HOW DO WE SOLVE THIS BUT WE
STILL HAVE CITIES -- THAT
REFUSED TO DO THAT AND THEY'RE
ACTUALLY IN LITIGATION SO AS
MUCH AS WE WANT TO SAY YES YOU
KNOW LET US HELP YOU -- I KNOW
WHAT I JUST MET WITH THE THE
DIRECTORS AND THE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT YESTERDAY AND AND
THEY'VE SHOWN ME THERE'S
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THEY'RE
WILLING.
TO ALMOST WALK PEOPLE THROUGH
THE PROCESS WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS
BILLS TODAY THAT HAVE SAID.
YOU KNOW LET'S GET THE DATE ALL
OF THESE THINGS BUT IN FIVE
YEARS.
AN ORANGE COUNTY WHICH IS THE
COUNTY THAT I'M FROM IF YOU
CAN'T COME UP WITH THE PLAN.
AND YOU CAN'T -- THERE THERE'S
COMMITTEE EVERY SO EXCUSE DOWN
THE DAY ANY EXCUSE POSSIBLE SO.
EVEN THOUGH THIS DOES SEEM
PUNITIVE.
AND I DO DEFINITELY BY THE TIME
IT GETS FLOOR OR TO THE FLOOR --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PARTY WOULD LIKE
TO SEE SOME MORE DEFINITION IN
THE TYPES OF GRANTS -- MAYBE
MOVING THAT FROM ALL TO A
SPECIFIED TYPE I DO SUPPORT THIS
TODAY -- BECAUSE WE HAVE TO STOP
WITH THE EXCUSES WE HAVE TO STOP
WITH ALL THE REASONS WE CAN'T DO
SOMETHING.
AND ELECTED MEMBERS ARE ELECTED
TO MAKE CHOICES AND SO DO YOUR
JOB.
DO YOUR JOB HAVING A HOUSING
PLAN AS PART OF A LOCAL A
MUNICIPALITY I SET OUT ON US.
COUNSEL FOR EIGHT YEARS THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE A LIKE DID TO DO AND
THAT'S WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN SO
ELECTED OFFICIALS DO YOUR JOB
OTHERWISE THERE'S THERE'S GOING
TO BE -- REWARDS AND
CONSEQUENCES SO I SUPPORT THIS
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YESTERDAY.
THANK YOU MISTER THE GERMAN --
AYE AYES HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
OTHER -- THIS BILL -- IT IS A
BLANK A BILL ACROSS THE STATE OR
IS.
AB -- A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
GENERAL LAW CITY IN A CHARTER
CITY.
YEAH THANK YOU -- IT'S RELATE TO
ALL CITIES THAT -- WITH OTHER
GENERAL LAW WORK CHARTER CITY
THEY STILL HAVE TO DO THAT THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT.
AND OF COURSE THERE'S A WILL
WELL PUBLICIZED CITY HEADS OUT
OF COMPLIANCE WHICH IS WHICH IS
YOUR CITY HUNTINGTON BEACH.
AND I I WILL SAY THAT I KNOW
YOU'RE CITIES WORKING ON THIS
AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT YOUR CITY
IS GOING.
TO CORRECT THIS ISSUE VERY
SHORTLY OF THE NEARLY FIFTY
CITIES THAT WERE ON THE LIST A
FEW MONTHS AGO. FOURTEEN ARE ARE
ON THEIR WAY OFF THE LIST
THEY'RE WORKING TO GET THERE.
AND CELL AND THERE'S OTHER
CITIES LIKE YOUR CITY MISSED
LAMONT FILLMORE WHO'S WHO'S
GONNA BE WORKING ON THIS GET ANY
MONEY IN THE BUDGET TO HELP
CITIES SMALLER CITIES.
FOCUS ON THEIR PLANET BECAUSE
SOME JURISDICTIONS MAY NOT HAVE
THE ROBUST PLANNING STAFF LIKE
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO LA
SACRAMENTO HAPPY.
SO IT WOULD APPLY TO TO EVERY
CITY IN CALIFORNIA BUT WE THINK
THERE'S AMPLE OPPORTUNITY FOR
CITIES TO DO THE RIGHT THING BUT
ALSO SUPPORT TO HELP THEM DO THE
RIGHT THING.
THANK YOU AND IN A BOOK BUT HE
SAID HOW TO THE BEACH IS THE
BIGGEST CITY IN IN MY DISTRICT
AND IT DID TAKE A LOT OF PUSHING.
THE FROM FROM A FEDERAL JUDGE
FROM A FROM SACRAMENTO WHEN LAST
WEEK.
OF THE CITY COUNCIL MILEY
ACTUALLY APPROVE A A HOMELESS
SHELTER IN HER THE BEACH AND IT.
IT WAS LIKE PULLING TEETH --
JUST TO GET THAT ONE SHOWED HER
APPROVING CONCEPT.
AND I A A BECAUSE OF THE OF THE
NATURE OF OF MY DISTRICT.
I WENT TO LAY OFF FOR YOUR BILL
TODAY AND I HOPE THAT WE WE GET
TO A POINT WHERE I COULD SUPPORT
A YOUR BILL ON THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THIS PAPER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO
THANK THE OFF THEIR I THINK MY
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES ON THE
OTHER SIDE THE DYSON SAID HAVE
EXPRESSED MOST OF WHAT I WAS
HOPING TO EXPRESS TODAY AND JUST.
WANTED TO ECHO THEIR COMMENTS I
THINK THE CARROT AND STICK
APPROACH IS REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A
MEANINGFUL STICK IN THERE TO
ENCOURAGE.
CITIES TO IT TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND HOLD FOLKS ACCOUNTABLE
I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO
PUT A LOT OF THOUGHT INTO HOW WE
CRAFT THAT STICK TO DEAL WITH A
LOT OF PRECISION SO THAT WE ARE.
NOT HAVING UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IN WHAT WE'RE DOING
SO PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY AND HOPE THAT
YOU'LL CONTINUE THESE
CONVERSATIONS WILL.
FOR ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
COLLEAGUES MISTER MCCARTY YES I
I THINK YOU FOR THE DIALOGUE FOR
THE CONSTRUCTIVE -- IDEAS GOING
FORWARD AND TO THOSE WHO CAME UP
AND EXPRESS THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT
SOME OF THE TECHNICAL ISSUES
WILL WILL WE'RE WORKING.
WITH YOU AND WE WILL DO SO GOING
FORWARD AND WITH THAT ASK YOUR
RIVAL THANK YOU I APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK YOU'VE DONE WITH US AND
ALL OF OUR MEMBERS TO WHAT
REFINED THE STICK.
DO WITH EMOTION.
MOTION AND IT'S MOVE MADAM
SECRETARY.
MOTION IS THE BEST TO THE
ASSEMBLY A COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TWO FIVE TWO I
DEEP ON FORTY EIGHT THE MORNING.
HI GABRIELLE GABRIEL I GLORIA
[inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
KILEY NO.
LEE MON.
LIMóN I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I FIVE SIX ONE FOR
YOUR BILL IS OUT THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES WHEN WE GO THROUGH
THE TOP THE AGENDA THROUGH THE
AGENDA TO MAKE SURE WE ADD
EVERYONE ON AND IF THE CALL
MISTER GLORIA HOPEFULLY BRING
HIM BACK SHORTLY.
MADAM SECRETARY LET'S START
AGAIN WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
KANSEN CONSENT CALENDAR HAS --
BILLS AB FORTY THREE A. B. ONE
NINETY FIVE A. B. FORTY NINE AB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE A. B..
NINE FIVE SEVEN AB [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN FORTY FIVE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I KILEY.
KILEY I MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
NINE LET'S GO TO THE TOP OF THE
AGENDA FILE ITEM ONE A. B. FIFTY
THREE JONES SAWYER WAS PULLED AB
TWO AB SIXTY SEVEN THREE OF US.
I'M [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA
[inaudible]
I ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I EIGHT TWO ZERO
FILE ITEM THREE AB ONE THIRTY
NINE QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I ASSEMBLY -- GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
KILEY I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
NIJE. EIGHT TWO ZERO AS A TWO
ZERO FILE ITEM SIX A. B.. FORTY
FOUR CALDERON [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEMOND.
THE MONEY HI MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I SEVEN ZERO NUMBER
IS SEVEN ZERO FILE ITEM EIGHT A.
B. FOR THIRTY FOUR DAILY.
GLORIA.
GLORIA I LEE MON THE MONTH I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN. NINE
EIGHT ZERO EIGHT ZERO FILE ITEM
NINE AB FOR THIRTY SEVEN WOOD.
GLORIA.
GLORIA I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I SIX SEVEN SEVEN
TWO ONE SEVEN ONE FILE ITEM TEN
AB SIX SEVENTY FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
GABRIELLE.
GABRIEL I GLORIA GLORIA I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT.
SIX SEVEN SEVEN ZERO ZERO FILE
ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
FOUR LEVINE.
MISSOURI YES.
GLORIA I KILEY KILEY AYE LEMOND.
THE ONE I AM MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA BY.
EIGHT ZERO BY THE ITEM TWELVE AB
SEVEN OH FIVE STONE WAS PULLED
A. B..
A FILE AND THIRTEEN AB SEVEN
TWENTY THREE WICKS.
GABRIELLE GABRIELLE I GLORIA.
LAURIE I KILEY KILEY IDEALLY MON.
THE MY NIGHT MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT QUIRK SILVA.
THANKS TO BUY EIGHT ZERO FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN AB. EIGHT SIXTEEN
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
GABRIELLE.
GABRIEL I KILEY [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I VOTED.
SEVEN ZERO GOING TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN A. B. TEN TEN EDUARDO
GARCIA.
GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
KILEY IDEALLY MON.
THE MONTH AYE QUIRK SILVA.
AYE QUIRK SILVA AYE THAT'S BIRDS.
EIGHT ZERO SANTIAGO AB.
ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN LIMóN
[inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I A SEVEN ZERO
FOLLOWED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
TWELVE NINETY GLORIA
[inaudible]
GABRIELLE [inaudible]
GABRIEL I GLORIA.
GLORIA I'D KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA BY VOTERS EIGHT ZERO
FILE AND TWENTY AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTEEN BRO [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I A GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE BUT IT'S EIGHT ZERO
FIVE AND TWENTY ONE AB FORTINO
FIVE GLORIA.
GABRIELLE.
GABRIELLE HI GLORIA GLORIA I'D
KILEY.
KILEY NO.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NINE
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I VOTED.
SEVEN TO ONE FILE ITEM TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY FOUR TINO'S SIX TANG.
GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
HIGHLY NO.
LEE MON.
A MONTH I QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE [inaudible]
HI. FIVE ONE THE BOAT IS FIVE TO
ONE THE BILLS OUT.
AB -- FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR WEEKS.
GABRIELLE.
GABRIEL I KILEY KILEY I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE BUT AS EIGHT
ZERO THE BILLS OUT FILE AND
TWENTY FOUR A. B. FIFTEEN SIXTY
ONE CRISTINA GARCIA.
GABRIELLE.
GABRIEL I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
BUT AS A TWO ZERO I LET THEM
TWENTY FIVE AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT I THINK EVERYONE HAS VOTED
ON THAT EXCEPT EXCEPT COME OUT
GLORIA.
GLORIA I VOTERS.
SEVEN TO ONE FOLLOW TWENTY SIX
AB SEVENTEEN OH TO LOOSE REAVIS.
GLORIA.
GLORIA I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN.
NINE NUMBER IS EIGHT ZERO FINAL
ITEM FILE FOR TWENTY SEVEN AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY MS CONSOLIDATES.
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
KILEY I EIGHT ZERO NUMBER IS A
TWO ZERO THAT CONCLUDES TODAY'S
HEARING WE WILL SEE EVERYONE
TOMORROW AT THE SPECIAL HEARING
OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AT THIS TIME WE ARE ADJOURNED